Und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren Ausgabe des Chaos Radios im Blue Moon hier auf Ritz, wie immer an einem Donnerstag, an einem letzten Donnerstag im Monat und wie immer mit einem Thema, das irgendwie mit diesem komischen Internet zu tun hat, das da draußen uns alle bewegt, unser Leben bestimmt und von Politikern verwaltet wird. Und das ist heute das Thema. Das Thema ist heute Netzpolitik. Was ist das eigentlich? Wo reden wir da gerade drüber? Und was kann man damit so anfangen? Da zu Gast sind im Studio wie immer Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, wie es im Chaos Radio ist. Und aus dem näheren freundschaftlichen Umfeld könnte man vielleicht sagen, da begrüße ich heute ganz recht herzlich Constanze Kurz, hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und Florian Gilberg, hallo und guten Abend. So und die haben auch schon wieder was gemeinsam. Also Constanze Kurz kennt man vielleicht aus Funk und Fernsehen, wie es so heißt oder auch aus der Presse. Als, ich bin aber nicht Sprecher des Chaos Computer Clubs, was ja eine deiner Funktion ist. Du bist ja eine der Sprecherinnen des Clubs. Aber du bist auch, und das relativ neu, beim Blog Netzpolitik Org. Aber das sozusagen, weil das wahrscheinlich auch eine Frage ist, die heute Abend auftauchen könnte. Das Blog Netzpolitik Org ist nicht die einzige Institution in Deutschland, die Netzpolitik macht.
Da wollen wir ja heute erstmal noch drüber reden.
Wer weiß, was dann noch kommt.
Genau. Florian Gilberg ist aber bei Netzpolitik Org und zwar als?
Redaktionspraktikant.
Was heißt das? Was macht man da? Wird man da ausgebeutet, wie das bei Pressepraktikanten so üblich ist?
Also ich habe bis jetzt erstaunlich wenig Kaffee gekocht, muss ich dazusagen. Ja, wir kümmern uns in der Praktikantenschau um alles, was so anfällt. Das heißt Recherche, Zurarbeit, aber auch eigene Texte und ja.
Wusstest du schon vorher, was Netzpolitik ist oder hast du das erst dort gelernt? Also jetzt das Thema, nicht das Blog.
Ich hatte vorher schon eine ziemlich gute Ahnung, was Netzpolitik ist und habe mich ganz bewusst darauf beworben und das ist dann auch glücklicherweise was geworden. Aber dann, wenn man in der Maschine, sag ich mal, drin ist, dann kriegt man auch ganz anderen Blick auf die Sachen.
Okay, wir wollen heute im Laufe der nächsten zwei Stunden klären, was Netzpolitik ist und was dafür Themen anstehen und was man machen kann. Und da seid natürlich auch ihr gefragt, liebe Hörer vor den neuartigen Grundfunk- und Fangsgeräten, falls ihr etwas habt, wo ihr denkt, da sollten sich unsere Politiker aber mal dringend drum kümmern und was auch immer es ist für ein Thema. Also wenn es mit dem Netz irgendwie zu tun hat, dann könnt ihr gerne folgendes tun, nämlich anrufen zu unter dieser Nummer. Weil es gibt ja wirklich, wenn es um das Internet geht, jede Menge Dinge, die man sich antun könnte, wo man sagen könnte, das stimmt alles noch nicht so richtig. Und das müssen gar nicht so überkomplexe Dinge sein wie Netzneutralität. Es kann auch was ganz einfaches sein, vielleicht Abmahnwesen oder irgendwelche solche Sachen. Also falls ihr etwas habt, wo ihr denkt, da sitzt die Politik ganz schön noch breit auf ihrem fetten Hintern und macht nichts, könnten sie aber mal, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. Oder wenn ihr sagt, das läuft doch total super, bei uns Netzpolitik in Deutschland ist total großartig. Könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen 0371 77 97 110. Bevor wir uns hier im Studio mit den Gästen ins Detail bewegen, wollen wir natürlich sozusagen könnte man ihn Herrn Netzpolitik nennen?
Ich weiß nicht, bis wir ihn fragen.
Also es gibt ja einen Namen in Deutschland, der sozusagen ist durch seine lange Arbeit mit dem Thema sehr damit verbunden mit diesem Begriff Netzpolitik und zwar sowohl mit dem Thema als auch mit dem Blog, das ist Markus Becke da, den wir jetzt am Telefon haben. Hallo und guten Abend. So Markus, dann erklär uns doch bitte einmal ganz kurz und knapp, was ist denn eigentlich Netzpolitik?
Also Netzpolitik dreht sich einerseits um die Frage, wie das Internet, die Digitalisierung, die Vernetzung, Gesellschaft, Politik und eigentlich alles verändert und andererseits auch wiederum, wie dann wiederum die Politik dieses Netz verändert durch Regulation, durch Gesetze, durch Schaffung von Normen und sonstigem.
Das ist das Thema Netzpolitik und was ist dein Blog Netzpolitik?
netzpolitik.org ist als Blog gestartet, als ja Plattform, wo ich erst mal angefangen hatte, alle relevanten Informationen zusammen zu tragen, die es damals so sperrlich rund um das Thema gab und ist angewachsen zu einem journalistischen Medium, wo mittlerweile fünf Menschen mehr oder weniger hauptberuflich mitarbeiten, drum herum eine große Anzahl an freiwilligen Mitarbeitern und oder Praktikanten. Und wir sind eigentlich im Moment mittlerweile der zentrale Ort für sämtliche netzpolitischen Debatten im deutschsprachigen Raum, aber auch darüber hinaus.
Uiui, ganz schön groß. Was arbeitet denn eigentlich ein Netzpolitikaktivist? Weil das ist so ein Schlagwort, worunter ihr immer so ein bisschen genannt werdet auch.
Na wir sind so eine Mischform aus Aktivisten und Journalisten. Wir nutzen journalistische Techniken. Wir schätzen auch die Pressefreiheit mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen und setzen uns aber ganz klar für Grundrechte im digitalen Zeitalter ein. Also wir sagen ganz klar, wir sind nicht objektiv. Objektiver Journalismus ist zwar erstrebenswert, wird aber fast nirgendswo praktiziert. Wir sagen, wir sind subjektiv, wir berichten journalistisch aus der Perspektive von digitalen Grundrechten und analysieren, was in der Politik passiert, analysieren die ganzen Gesetzesprozesse aus der Perspektive von digitalen Grundrechten, recherchieren aber auch Missstände, veröffentlichen regelmäßig viele Dokumente, die uns zugeschickt werden und für die bisher noch kein Platz im Netz war und versuchen aus unserer Perspektive die öffentliche Debatte auch mit zu entfachen, teilweise bei Themen, wo der Rest der Gesellschaft wahrscheinlich erst ein paar Jahre später anfängt, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen. Sind wir schon diejenigen, die quasi sagen, da rast was auf uns zu. Wir sollten uns Gedanken machen. Wir sollten auch aufpassen, dass nicht irgendwelche Industrielobbys ja quasi in den Hinterzimmern jetzt schon irgendwelche Weichen legen, die dann später nachteilig für uns als Bürger oder als Verbraucher sein werden.
Ich habe Netzpolitik immer erlebt, als dann sehr wir gegen die oder die gegen uns. Also es gab da die Aktivisten, die Nerds quasi, dann gab es die Politiker, dann kam später noch irgendwie die Industrie dazu. Wie wichtig in dieser Rolle ist denn eigentlich noch oder in diesem ganzen Themengebiet ist denn überhaupt noch der normale User, also quasi jetzt auch die Hörer dieser Sendung oder halt irgendwelche anderen Leute?
Wir sind die wichtigsten. Also ich meine, wir sind die Bürger, wir sind die Nutzer.
Da muss ich gleich noch mal fragen, siehst du dich tatsächlich noch als Teil dessen oder bist du nicht Teil sozusagen eines politischen Betriebs, der sich auch schon sozusagen so ein bisschen verselbstständig hat?
Du meinst jetzt, ob wir uns in irgendeiner Blase bewegen, wo man nicht mehr genau weiß, was der normale Nutzer denkt? Das glaube ich nicht. Also einerseits, wir stehen ja in ständigen Interaktionen, nicht nur mit unserer Community, die aus teilweise 40.000 Leserinnen und Lesern am Tag besteht. Wir gehen ja auch sehr häufig raus. Also wir sind auf sehr vielen Veranstaltungen, Diskussionen präsent. Und wir sind so eine Art Brücke zwischen den Nerds, den Hackern auf der einen Seite, denjenigen, die am austesten sind. Was sind so die Grenzen der Digitalisierung, die wir gerade erleben und dem Rest der Gesellschaft? Und wir versuchen, als so diese Brückenfunktion auch gegenseitiges Verständnis zu wecken und gleichzeitig aber auch Übersetzer zu spielen zwischen dem, was da im Netz passiert und dem, was die Gesellschaft jetzt vielleicht noch nicht ganz realisiert oder inwiefern sie davon betroffen ist.
Jetzt noch eine letzte Frage an dich, das ist die, ob du eine Frage hast. Also es gibt ja heute die Möglichkeit, die anzurufen unter 0331 77 97 110 und vielleicht eine Frage zur Netzpolitik zu stellen oder auch zu beantworten. Was würdest du denn gerne von den Hörern wissen im Bezug auf dieses Themenfeld?
Also ich würde gerne wissen, was die Gründe sind, was Menschen abhält, für ihre eigenen Rechte einzutreten. Also Netzpolitik geht uns alle an, die Gestaltung des digitalen Raums geht uns alle an. Eigentlich sollte da jeder zusehen, dass er oder sie sich daran beteiligt, weil wenn wir jetzt nicht genau aufpassen, dann werden wir irgendwann vielleicht in Unfreiheit oder noch wären wir in Unfreiheit im digitalen Raum unterwegs sein. Und da ist ja die Frage, was hält euch ab, gegen diese ganzen Missstände jetzt nicht aktiv zu werden.
Alles klar, ihr habt es gehört, liebe Leute da draußen, was haltet ihr ab, euch an Netzpolitik zu beteiligen oder viel zu interessieren? Markus Becke, da war das Netzpolitik Aktivist vom Blog Netzpolitik Org mit dem Thema Netzpolitik. So, da haben wir es geklärt, von dem an, der ist quasi, man kann schon mal große Worte benutzen, der Mann, der zu sagen dafür verantwortlich ist, hauptsächlich mit, dass dieses Thema auch so groß ist in Deutschland. Und wie gesagt, die Frage an euch geht raus, wie viel macht ihr selber Netzpolitik und wenn ihr nicht viel macht, und das klickt ja so ein bisschen durch, dieses zu sagen, wir reißen uns hier den Hintern auf und machen ganze Netzpolitik, aber wenige Leute machen damit. Was hält sich davon ab oder was interessiert euch daran nicht? Ich frage mich jetzt die ganze Zeit noch, wie man das anders formulieren kann.
Da ist so ein bisschen höherer Beschimpfung am Anfang, oder?
Naja, aber wenn jetzt jemand sagt, seit wie vielen Jahren gibt es das Blog und die Arbeit geht es auch schon ein bisschen länger. Na, über zehn Jahre. Wenn das die erste Frage ist, die ihm einfällt, die Frage, warum interessiert ihr euch nicht dafür, dann ist ja vielleicht doch ein bisschen was dran, könnte sein.
Da muss man vielleicht der Ehrlichkeit herbeisagen, das war ja nicht sozusagen eine abgesprachene Frage, sondern die musste er ja spontan.
Die musste er sich jetzt spontan ausdenken. Vielleicht ist ja auch darauf, dass jemand denkt, Moment mal, das stimmt überhaupt gar nicht, ich mache ja voll Netzpolitik und interessiere mich und so, dann kann auch gerne anrufen, 0373, 971, so, bevor wir zu Constanze Kurz kommen, die ja auch schon ein bisschen länger in dem Thema drin steckt, Florian, was ist denn eigentlich Netzpolitik? Also warst du jetzt sozusagen ein paar Monate, zwei, drei Monate?
Seit Anfang Januar, genau.
Seit Anfang Januar, Praktikant bei Netzpolitik, hast du gemeint, du hast dich vorher für das Thema schon interessiert, was hat dich da interessiert, wie bist du da hingekommen?
Es ist halt, ja, ich habe auch schon mit vielen Leuten, mit anderen drüber gesprochen, es ist halt sehr unterschiedlich, wie Leute an das Thema rangekommen sind. Bei mir ist es ganz akut losgegangen mit den Enthüllungen von Ed Wood Snowden. Oder sogar noch ein bisschen früher in der ganzen Materie, weil Netzpolitik ist auch Urheberrecht, finde ich, viel, ist es mit den ganzen Agda-Demonstrationen losgegangen, wo wirklich viele, viele auf die Straße gegangen sind und gezeigt haben, dass es so nicht funktioniert, dass Geheimverhandlungen, die uns alle betreffen und uns in unseren Grundrechten im Internet beschränken, dass das so nicht passieren kann.
Okay, also jetzt mal kurz, das Notenenthüllung, da gehe ich jetzt davon aus, das hat vielleicht schon jeder gehört, diese Sendung hört auch nur zufällig, aber Agda, ganz kurz erklären, was das ist?
Agda, das war eine Initiative auf der europäischen Ebene, die im Geheimen, wie jetzt übrigens auch TTIP verhandelt werden sollte, die Urheberrecht im Internet...
Das sollte quasi ein internationaler, ein Abkommen sein zwischen sehr vielen Ländern. Also das heißt, glaube ich, der Schreibpunkt war im Wesentlichen, dass die Verhandlungen und die Inhalte sehr lange geheim waren. Das hat den Protest glaube ich sehr befeuert.
Ganz genau und darüber auch mit der Transparenz, dass man da halt dann hingekommen ist, dass man einfach merkt, Mensch, da passieren Sachen, die uns alle extrem betreffen werden in nicht allzu feiner Zukunft und dagegen muss man was tun.
Aber was hatte das für dich mit dem Netz zu tun? Also was sozusagen, was macht das ganze Netz politisch?
Ja, einfach der Eingriff in die Freiheit. Das, was ich persönlich als meine Freiheit im Internet wahrnehme. Und zwar eben, da muss ich jetzt aufpassen, dass ich jetzt nicht in die Raubkuppee-Recke gestellt werde. Ja, aber der Freiheit von Informationen. Natürlich auch von Inhalten von Künstlern. Und ich meine, es gibt auch Modelle mittlerweile, die sich entwickelt haben, die Künstler auch entlohnen, die halt von fixen Bezahlmodellen weggegangen sind. Also Streaming-Portal zum Beispiel. Aber sowas wäre mit ACTA zum Beispiel ja auch nur sehr eingeschränkt, denke ich mal, möglich gewesen.
So, jetzt haben wir schon sagen, innerhalb des Versuches zu erklären, was Netzpolitik eigentlich ist, haben wir schon Snowden-Enthüllungen, Geheimverhandlungen zu einem Wirtschaftsabkommen und die Frage, wie ist es eigentlich mit dem Urheberrecht im Internet? Kannst du noch mal zusammenfassen, was ist Netzpolitik?
Netzpolitik ist ein großer Haufen Themen und die werden auch gefühlt immer mehr und es ist teilweise schwer, wie du das sagst, den Überblick zu behalten. Für jeden ist, und das ist auch irgendwie wichtig, für jeden ist Netzpolitik auch irgendwie ein bisschen was anderes, mit dem ich so ein bisschen gesprochen habe. Jeder setzt da andere Schwerpunkte. Viele sagen, Mensch, ich fühle mich von Gehealdiensten extrem bedroht und überwacht. Andere sagen, ich finde nicht gut, was Internetunternehmen mit meinen Daten machen, was die erheben, wieder andere sagen, Mensch, die Netzneutralität, das ist ein Thema. Wir brauchen alle, wir müssen alle vom, alle Pakete sollen gleich behält werden, alle sollen die gleichen Chancen im Internet haben, wieder andere sind beim Urheberrecht und so weiter. Also es ist ein dreiter dritten Palette, die aber in der Summe genommen so eine unglaubliche Auswirkung auf uns alle hat und jetzt schon hat, in der Vergangenheit hat und auch in der Zukunft haben wird, dass es sehr bedeutsam ist, da genau hinzugucken.
Okay, also zusammengefasst, so irgendwas mit Internet und das ist wichtig, weil es überall ist. Constanze Kurz, was ist Netzpolitik?
Da bin ich schon gespannt.
Einfach und verständlich erklärt.
Ich glaube natürlich, dass meine Sicht ein bisschen einfach eine andere ist, weil schließlich die Kämpfe sich ja länger ziehen. Mir ist Florian einfach ein bisschen jünger als ich selbst und wenn man so zehn Jahre sich mit diesen Sachen auseinandersetzt, dann hat man einen anderen Blickwinkel. Ich habe mich lange mit diesem Begriff Netzpolitik nicht so richtig anfreunden können und hatte lange Probleme. Ich fand es immer besser Technologiepolitik zu nennen oder Digitalpolitik. Mittlerweile sehe ich aber auch einfach ein, dass sich der Begriff irgendwie etabliert hat. Es war halt mal eine Nische, wo sich wenige, die sich mit Technik auskannten, über ziemlich enge Kreise und deren Regulierung gestritten haben. Wenn man heute darauf blickt, ist es halt ganz klar, oft sehr viele wirtschaftliche Fragen, die sich damit verbinden. Klar, in den Beispielen, die Florian so hatte, sieht man ja gut. Die Akterproteste sind auf jeden Fall auch Proteste gewesen gegen die Durchsetzung der kommerziellen Interessen ohne Nutzerbeteiligung. Also da ging es sicherlich auch um ökonomische Interessen. Und wenn man jetzt auf die letzten Beispiele von Florian blickt, jetzt die Enthüllung von Edward Snowden, da kommen wir an eine ganz andere Ebene von Spitzenpolitik, also längst nicht mehr diese technische Nische. Und dann ist für mich natürlich Netzpolitik, ich würde es schon noch ein bisschen weiterfassen, neben der Urheberrechtsdebatte gehört für mich heute dazu auch die Gestaltung von unserer Arbeitswelt. Wie arbeiten wir mit Maschinen? Wie gehen wir damit um? Wie ändert sich ein Zusammenleben, wenn es dominiert ist, einfach durch die technische Infrastruktur, durch die Geräte, die wir mit uns rumtragen? Also für mich sind die Fragen größer geworden mit den Jahren, aber deshalb natürlich umso spannender, klar.
Aber jetzt ist alles, was ihr sagt, hat damit zu tun, Netzpolitik ist, wie wir mit dem Internet umgehen, oder wie wir mit dem Internet umgehen dürfen, oder was dort passieren darf oder was andere dürfen. Aber das ist die Frage, ob wir überhaupt Internet haben, ist keine Netzpolitik.
Ich würde sagen, dass die Breitbandfrage, also sowas wie, ist das eigentlich was, womit eine Bevölkerung versorgt werden muss, deutlich dazuzählt, wird doch an den Jahren, jetzt in den letzten drei Jahren würde ich sagen, netzpolitisch ziemlich stark mit debattiert. Es gibt noch einen Aspekt, den wir nicht so hatten bisher, zur Netzpolitik gehören für mich heute sehr viel mehr rechtliche Fragen als früher. Einfach klar, es gibt sowieso mehr Gesetzesvorhaben, aber es wird auch sehr häufig sehr juristisch argumentiert. Während früher die Diskussionen sehr viel mehr oder viel mehr nur technisch waren. Ich glaube, da hat sich eine Menge getan, woran man sehr gut sehen konnte, was eigentlich Netzpolitik ist, war in der letzten Legislaturperiode die Enquete-Kommission des Bundestags, die ja so ein breites Feld hatte. Nein, der Bundestag hat sich eine Enquete-Kommission, die eine Untersuchungskommission ist, gegeben, die sozusagen alle netzpolitischen Themen in unterschiedlicher Qualität und Zeit debattiert hat. Dazu gehörten dann aber auch Bürgerbeteiligungen, Transparenzfragen, Open-Data-Fragen, sehr breites Feld. Diese Untersuchungskommission hatte das Ziel, die zukünftigen Politiker zu beraten, indem sie einen abschließenden Bericht verfasst und versucht hat, eine Analyse zu machen.
Wir haben gleich noch einen Anrufer, glaube ich. Da geht es natürlich auch um das Breitbanding. Noch kurz eine Frage zu der Enquete-Kommission. Experten setzen sich hin und sagen der Politik, was sie von dem ganzen Thema halten.
Ich fand ganz spannend, wie sich die zusammensetzten. So eine Enquete-Kommission ist zur Hälfte Politiker, die andere Hälfte sind Sachverständigen. Die Sachverständigen bildeten ziemlich gut ab, was Staatspolitik heute ist. Die überwiegende Teil im konservativen Lager waren kommerzielle Lobbyisten. Während es sich auf den Oppositionsbänken, die verschiedenen NGOs oder eben Markus Beckender war auch bei, für Netzpolitik Org. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Für die SPD saß eine Vertreterin vom Braucherschutzzentral. Das war interessant, wie sich genau die Streits, nämlich um Geld und Juristen waren natürlich auch da, wie sich die so abbildeten in Person.
Das heißt, ich wollte eigentlich jetzt die Frage stellen, haben die Politiker überhaupt darauf gehört, was die Experten gesagt haben? Aber dann hat quasi jeder die Experten eingeladen, die das gesagt haben, was man eh schon geglaubt hat.
Ja, der damalige Regierungslager, bestehend noch aus FDP und CDU, hat auch immer ausschließlich und immer im Blog abgestimmt. Da haben sich leider auch die Sachverständigen, die von diesen Fraktionen berufen wurden, immer in einer Regel jedenfalls diesem Votum angepasst. Das war schon sehr geprägt von dieser Proporzpolitik, wie sie in der Bundespolitik üblich ist.
Auch die Akteure sind ja auch teilweise immer noch dieselben, die immer wieder auftauen. Jetzt zum Beispiel in der Enquete-Kommission war ja auch der Herr Gorni, über den wir gerade jetzt rundetan wieder ganz aktuell am Berichten sind, aus der Musikindustrie, der sich schon seit Jahrzehnten aktiv für die schaffen eines viel rechtssichereren Raums, wie er es gerne nennt, denke ich mal, im Internet einsetzt und für die Musikindustrie halt da eben lobbyiert. Und uns am besten alle nach drei Filzstreiken, die wir alle frei haben, nach drei Strikes das Internet abnehmen will, wenn es ihm gehen würde.
Der Herr Gorni ist ja sozusagen eine ganz schöne Personalie, weil er der Chef des Bundesverbands der Musikindustrie ist und jetzt berufen wurde vom Wirtschaftsminister Gabriel als Berater für digitale Ökonomie.
Ich finde es interessant, wie wenig Leute sich darum am Kopf kratzen, dass ein hauptberuflicher Lobbyist für einen großen Verband der Musikindustrie als Netzpolitiker spielt. Interessant natürlich auch welche Kompetenzerwartungen an so einer Position.
Man muss noch mal einen Schritt zurück geben, wenn man gar nicht so in dem Thema drinsteckt. Ist es wirklich so ungewöhnlich, dass ein Lobbyist als Berater eines Politikers da sitzt an der Stelle? Also erstmal, egal welche Richtung er einnimmt, aber dass da Leute sitzen, die Experten in ihrem Fach sind und natürlich eine eigene Meinung haben, ist das jetzt normal oder unnormal?
Man sieht es auch an ganz vielen Beispielen. Zum Beispiel auch wenn wir auf die EU-Ebene gucken, ist es eigentlich gang und gäbe. Der Herr Oettinger, der auch einer unserer lieben Bekannten ist, über den wir sehr oft berichten, gibt in seinen Reden eins zu eins Argumente wieder, die wir immer und immer wieder aus Lobbypapieren von Telekommunikationsunternehmen oder deren Zuarbeitsfirmen hören. Beispielsweise das telemedizinische Infrastruktur, dass es essenziell ist und deswegen müssen wir das Internet die Gleichheit abschaffen und solche Anwendungen eben für...
Das sind schon wieder Katastrophen, sehr sehr sehr sehr.
Ich könnte schon wieder extrem aufhören, aber...
Das sind vor allem sehr viele Themen da schon drin. Da geht es dann um die Netzneutralität, also den Datenverkehr. Da wird ein Argument rausgezogen, wo gesagt wird, das ist ganz wichtig, deswegen müssen wir es überall machen. Ich wollte da erst mal noch gar nicht hin, sondern ich wollte erst mal dahin sagen, dass Politiker von Leuten beraten werden, die ein Lobbyist sind, das heißt, die eine eigene Meinung vertreten und die natürlich beim Polyamoren wollen. Ist das unnormal?
Ich glaube, das ist normal geworden. Der Lobbyismus ist natürlich über die Netzpolitik hinaus ein Problem. Wir nehmen heute glaube ich sehr viel stärker hin, dass kommerzielle Verbände wirtschaftliche Interessen so durchdrücken. Nicht nur, also meine Florian sagt es auf europäischer Ebene ähnlich. Ich würde das aber nicht auf die Netzpolitik beschränken. Das ist natürlich auch ein gewisser Kompetenzverlust bei Berufspolitikern, die solche Art von Beratung suchen und brauchen. Aber dass wir es hinnehmen als Bevölkerung, dass sozusagen dort ganz klare wirtschaftliche Interessen, die mit Gemeinwohlinteressen nicht immer die gleichen sind. Zu sagen, in der Tagespolitik Beratungen da sind, ist glaube ich ein neuere Phänomen seit vielleicht 15 Jahren.
Aber das wäre ja nicht schlimm, wenn da Lobbyisten aus jeder Richtung sitzen. Und jetzt ist die Frage, seht ihr euch auch als Lobbyisten?
Also ich würde mich schon als Lobbyist bezeichnen in dem Sinne, dass ich den Begriff nicht prinzipiell negativ konnotieren würde. Denn es gibt Lobbyisten, die keine kommerziellen Interessen vertreten, sondern eher zu sagen, die Menschen oder bürgerrechtliche Ziele haben. Also ich finde den Lobbyismusbegriff nicht nur negativ. Mich stört, wenn ganz klare rein wirtschaftliche Interessen dahinterstehen. Manchmal ist es durchaus so, dass wirtschaftliche Interessen nicht unbedingt gemeinwohl gefährdend sind. Ich will ja nicht total wirtschaftsweihendlich sein. Es gibt ja manchmal Sachen, wo Bürgerrechte und Wirtschaftsinteressen durchaus gemeinschaftlich am selben Strang ziehen könnten. Das gibt es ja. Aber insgesamt finde ich das natürlich schwierig, wenn man das allgemein formulieren will, weil das Politik macht. Ich glaube, dass Politiker eine andere Rolle haben, nämlich dass sie eigentlich die Interessen ihrer Bürger vertreten.
Nein, aber noch mal, die Netzpolitik hat verschiedene Interessen. Die Netzaktivisten sagen immer, wir vertreten Interessen der normalen Bürger. Die Wirtschaft sagt, das machen wir auch, aber ein bisschen anders, weil wir sozusagen unsere Produkte an den Mann bringen wollen. Dann könnte man sagen, das ist doch alles gar kein Problem, weil sozusagen jede Interessengruppe schickt dann ihre Vertreter zum Politiker und sagt, die konkrete Frage wäre, der Herr Gorni ist jetzt Berater beim Herrn Gabriel. Ist denn da auf irgendeine Art und Weise sichergestellt, dass da sozusagen auch andere Leute an den Herrn Gabriel in diese Art und Weise rankommen, wie der Herr Gorni ist?
Ich würde schon sagen, dass das nicht die einzige Beratung ist. Klar, Gabriel wird als Wirtschaftsminister mit vielen reden und im Wirtschaftsministerium wahrscheinlich sehr viel mit Wirtschaftsverbänden. Ich würde aber schon sagen, dass das ein Ressourcenproblem ist. Das merkt man ja seit vielen Jahren in der Netzpolitik besonders. Wenn man plötzlich mit kommerziellen Verbänden zu tun hat, das hat sich in den letzten zehn Jahren so entwickelt, dass die natürlich andere Ressourcen haben. Viele Mitarbeiter haben eine andere Möglichkeit, PR zu machen, als in der Regel Bürgerrechtsgruppen können. Oder kleinere NGOs wie die Free Software Foundation oder wie auch der CCC, der ehrenamtlich arbeitet. Oder auch eine kleine Redaktion wie Netzpolitik Org. Das ist eine Ressourcenfrage. Da gibt es große Wirtschaftsunternehmen, die viel Geld in die Verbände haben. Das ist eine gewisse Macht-Asymmetrie.
Ich fasse mal erst kurz zusammen, Netzpolitik ist ganz schön viel, was mit dem Internet zu tun hat. Das Ziel von Netzpolitik ist, die Politiker zu beeinflussen, die dann bestimmte Regelungen treffen. Das erste Problem, das wir haben, ist, dass die nicht selber Entscheidungen treffen, sondern beraten werden. Beraten in Anführungszeichen, weil die Leute, die sie beraten, eigen Interessen durchsetzen. Die können lautstärker vorgebracht werden von den Wirtschaftsverbänden, weil die mehr Manpower haben an dieser Stelle.
Ich würde es nicht ganz so generalisieren. In den Jahren gibt es mittlerweile in allen Parteien auch Netzpolitiker, die eine hohe technische Kompetenz haben.
Weil wir gleich Nachricht machen, wir können es ja nachher noch genau beschreiben. Die Frage ist, okay, erster Fakt, den schreiben wir uns auf, wir behandeln ihn nachher noch mal. Ist eine Partei immer eine Meinung oder gibt es eine unterschiedliche Meinung, was Netzpolitik angeht? Frage, Leute, die von Netzpolitik eher viel Ahnung haben, sitzen die auch auf Entscheidungsstellen oder sind das Leute, die in der Partei irgendwo hinten dran sind?
Auf Entscheidungsstellen sitzen Macht- und Schwitzenpolitiker. Die sind in der Regel durch andere Kompetenzen als Sachkompetenzen.
Alles klar, dann halten wir das fest. An der Spitze der Netzpolitik sitzen Machtpolitiker, nicht Fachpolitiker. Interessant. Wir klären gleich alles weitere, was man noch über Netzpolitik wissen kann. Vorher gibt es aber erst mal die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten. Das sind ja nicht nur die ganz großen. Wie Crowe, Yandilay und Criseau. Sondern auch neue Bands, die gerade total steil gehen. Wie Bilderbuch, Annen mal Kante Reit und Cheesy. Und natürlich auch neue Entdeckungen, die wir euch unbedingt mal vorstellen wollen. Freitag 4. und Samstag 5. September live im IFA-Sommergarten der Messe Berlin. Gibt es Karten im Kombiticket für beide Tage. Oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. Mehr dazu fritz.de slash Deutschpoeten.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Das fritz.opener Festival.
In Düsseldorf ist am Nachmittag die Wohnung des Co-Piloten der abgestützten German Wings Maschine durchsucht worden. Die Ermittler hoffen, Hinweise auf sein Motiv zu bekommen. Der 27-Jährige soll die Maschine vorgestern absichtlich zum Absturz gebracht haben, als der Kapitän das Cockpit kurz verließ. Das sagten heute die Ermittler in Frankreich, die die Aufnahmen aus dem Stimmrekorder ausgewertet haben. Air Berlin, EasyJet und mehrere andere Fluggesellschaften haben inzwischen festgelegt, dass kein Pilot mehr allein im Cockpit bleiben darf. Am Unglücksort in Südfrankreich geht die Bergung der Leichen weiter. Die Polizei sagt, dass das wegen der schwierigen Lage bis zu 2 Wochen dauern könnte. Die Leichen werden in einem provisorisch eingerichteten Labor in der Nähe untersucht. Mehr als 30 Spezialisten und Rechtsmediziner arbeiten an der Identifizierung. In Berlin hat die Echo-Verleihung mit einer Schweigeminute für die Opfer der abgestürzten Germanwings-Maschine begonnen. Als Zeichen der Trauer waren auf der Bühne 150 Kerzen aufgestellt. Eine für jeden Toten. Die ersten Echoes wurden schon verliehen. Zum zweiten Mal hat Helene Fischer den Preis für das Album des Jahres gewonnen. Den Echo als bester deutscher Künstler in der Kategorie Rockpop bekam Herbert Grönemeyer. An vielen Berliner Schulen ist heute Unterricht ausgefallen. Auch einige Prüfungen mussten verschoben werden. Schuld war ein Warnstreik der Angestellten Lehrer. Sie gingen am Mittag für eine bessere Bezahlung auf die Straße. Aus Brandenburg kamen etwa 500 Lehrerinnen und Lehrer zur Demo nach Berlin. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick 6 und in Kreuzberg 7 Grad, in Rheinsberg 4, in Potsdam und Lindenberg 6 und in Cottbus 7 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es weitgehend trocken bei 5 bis 3 Grad. Morgen wird es kühl bei 8 bis 12 Grad. Dazu wieder viele Wolken und ab und zu auch Regen. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A111, Stadtautobahn, Stadtauswärts. Zwischen Weitmannsduster Damm und Schulzendorfer Straße ist die Straße wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Das Ganze noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Neukölln und Kreuzberg, Cottbuser Damm bis Adelbertstraße. Ab Hobrechtstraße Richtung Oranienstraße müsste wegen einer Demo mit Behinderungen rechnen. Charlottenburg-Masurenallee zwischen Theodor-Holzplatz und Messe-Damm gibt es Behinderungen wegen der Echo-Verleihung. Das Ganze noch bis morgen früh 5 Uhr. Mitte, die in Berlinstraße ist zwischen Gartenstraße und Karoline, Michaelestraße wegen Bauarbeiten Richtung Moabit gesperrt und nach Brandenburg auf der A9 Berlin Richtung Leipzig. Zwischen Beelitz und Brück gab es einen Unfall. Da liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn und die rechte Spur ist gesperrt. Allen unterwegs eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt......oder diesen Sound......dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Chacon. Immer dienstags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon mit Markus Richter. Hallo und guten Abend. Und im Chaosradio sind immer Leute vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast. Heute in Gestalt von Constanze Kurz. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und zu Gast vom Blog Netzpolitik Org ist Florian Gilberg. Hallo und guten Abend. Und wir sprechen heute mal ganz allgemein über Netzpolitik. Was ist denn das eigentlich? Weil das ist jetzt schon sozusagen so ein allgemein verwendeter Terminus. Immer mal wieder fällt der Netzpolitik Dinge werden da entschieden. Und man weiß vielleicht gar nicht mehr so genau, was das ist, wer dahinter steckt. Und das wollen wir heute Abend alles mal erklären. Natürlich auch die Themen, um die es ja gehen soll. Und ihr sollt anrufen. Ihr sollt anrufen, wenn ihr glaubt, bei der Politik, die in unserem Land gemacht wird, da fehlt noch was in Bezug auf das Internet. Das Internet ist euch zu schmal, was ihr bekommt. Oder da gibt es euch zu viele Verbote oder vielleicht auch zu wenige. Und all diese Dinge könnt ihr tun. Und heute mal loswerden hier im Chaosradio in Blumen, wenn ihr Folgendes tut und zwar anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Vielleicht ärgert euch ja auch oder ihr findet super, dass Herr Gabriel gerade vorgeschlagen hat, dass Vorratsdatenspeicherung noch eine total super Sache wäre. So, erst noch kurz die erste halbe Stunde zusammenfassen. Wir haben schon mal geklärt, was Netzpolitik ist, nämlich so grob irgendwie alles, was im Internet reguliert werden kann, darf und soll. Und das Problem ein bisschen ist die Entscheidungen darüber, was Netzpolitik ist oder was da passiert werden von den großen Politikern an den Spitzen. Also von den Ministern und den Vorsitzenden getroffen. Und das sind, wie Constanze vorhin gesagt hat, Machtpolitiker, keine Sachpolitiker. Das heißt, ich entnehme dem sozusagen, die haben nicht so doll viele Ahnung von dem Thema, lassen sich deswegen halt immer beraten. Und beraten tun die Leute, die am besten an die Politiker rankommen. Und das sind eher die Wirtschaftsverbände mit viel Geld und Manpower, die Lobbyisten anstellen können, nicht so sehr die Nichtregierungsorganisationen, wie es so schön heißt. Die Themen können wir gleich noch besprechen, ihr seid ja wie gesagt aufgerufen, anzurufen, um zu sagen, was euch in der deutschen Netzpolitik stört. Und Lennart hat zum Telefonhörer gegriffen, aus Berlin Mitte, 17 Jahre alt. Hallo Lennart.
Ja, meine Frage ist, wenn ich das Thema Netzpolitik höre, warum gibt es im Jahre 2015 immer noch so schöne Probleme mit der Namenstrostlung? Ich bin stationär mit dem Internet unterwegs und mit dem Smartphone ist es eigentlich kein Problem. Aber wenn man quasi allgemein nur über das mobile Funknetz zugreifen kann, dann ist es doch echt kacke, wenn man auf Steinzeitniveau surfen darf.
Also dass das sozusagen, dass das störend ist, das wird sicherlich jeder bestätigen können, der in der Mitte des Monats mal die Meldung bekommt, so wir drosteln sie im Internetverkehr, buchen sie zu für 400 Milliarden Euro, ein weiteres Megabyte. Aber bevor wir über das Wurm reden, wollen wir von dir gleich gerne noch mal wissen, hättest du gerne von der Politik, dass sie das ändern, also dass sie sagen, dass sie quasi der Wirtschaft verbieten zu drosteln? Okay, gut, wir können ja gleich noch mal genau über Lösungsvorstöge diskutieren. So hier liebe Netzpolitik-Aktivisten, warum gibt es immer noch eine Drostelung? Warum habt ihr da nichts gemacht? Ihr hättet doch mal hier das irgendwie klären können bitte.
Ja, es tut uns extrem leid, dass wir das nicht schon früher getan haben. Nein, also ja, Lennart, ganz konkret zu deiner Frage. Da kann man das wieder extrem sehen. Ich meine, wer bringt dir das Internet auf dein Handy? Das machen ja die Telekommunikationsunternehmen. Und das machen ja auch andere Provider, die das bei dir durch die Telefonbuchse zu Hause ins Fehlen bringen. Und die haben natürlich ein Interesse daran, Geld zu verdienen. Und die haben dann halt gemerkt, als es dann hochkam mit den Smartphones, Mensch, die Leute wollen unterwegs aufs Internet auch zugreifen und zwar nicht so sich dann Jambaklingeltöne wie früher runterladen, sondern auch wirklich echt surfen. Mensch, da können wir doch mal ein anderes Modell einführen. Und dann machen wir halt nicht die Flatrate, weil wir merken, da gibt es halt nicht so viel Geld mit, sondern wir sagen halt, okay, du...
Eine Flatrate ist es immer noch. Ich kriege ja unendlich viel Daten. Es wird nur halt gedrosselt. Ich muss ja nicht Zusatz teilen, wenn ich quasi nicht Hayend Speed haben möchte.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Da wollte ich noch kurz einreden. Die Spitzenfindigkeit der Telekommunikationsanbieter übernommen. Die sagen, was wollt ihr denn, ist doch eine echte Flatrate, weil man kriegt ja die ganze Zeit Internet. Fakt ist aber natürlich, dass wenn das sozusagen gedrosselt wird, dass es eigentlich nicht funktioniert. Also ich habe das selber ausprobieren dürfen. Und wenn man sozusagen moderne Internetangebote, was heißt moderne, zeitgemäße Internetangebote versucht zu nutzen, wenn man irgendwie GPRS hat, das kann man vergessen. Also das ist im Prinzip kein Internet. Aber was steckt denn jetzt dahinter? Also sagen, klar, es gibt das wirtschaftliche Interesse, wenn wir, wir können halt mehr Geld damit machen. Aber wieso gibt es denn keine oder gibt es denn überhaupt eine Politik dazu?
Es gibt die Politik, die das versucht zu regulieren. Aber die ist halt sehr schwach. Die Telekommunikationslobby, die wir ja in der ersten Heimstunde schon drauf gekommen sind, ist sehr stark und der Borstenverband, da haben die das zum Beispiel mitkommen, hat halt ein Interesse daran, dass das so bleibt, wie es momentan ist, weil man kann mehr Geld damit verdienen. Und die Leute, die sagen, wir wollen freies, offenes Internet, unbegrenzt, überall, jederzeit. Da wird halt mit ganz vielen anderen Sachen auch gegenargumentiert.
Also wir haben glaube ich mehrere Probleme, die man so politisch angehen kann, wenn man so diesen Bereich betrachtet. Einmal die ganze Frage von Breitband, also inwieweit muss ein Staat irgendwie Anreize für wirtschaftliche Unternehmen setzen, dass sie möglichst gut ausbauen, also möglichst gute Kapazitäten anbieten können. Dann die Frage, die sich ja auch oft an die Politik richtet, wie transparent müssen Unternehmen sein in Bezug auf so eine, also Preise und Rostlungen, sodass also die Verbraucher, wenn es einen Wettbewerb gibt, auch gut vergleichen können. Damit man eben wirklich sagen kann, ah, wenn ich einen neuen Vertrag mache, wer bietet mir wirklich welche Kondition und muss nicht 90 Seiten kleinen Text lesen. Also diese Fragen sind ja eher politische Fragen, weil da könnten ja die politischen Entscheidungsträger, zum Beispiel im Übrigen von uns wie Gesetzen, mehr Transparenz herstellen. Die könnten ja zum Beispiel Unternehmen zwingen, um die Leute ja klarzustellen, was sie eigentlich für Konditionen haben. Dann kann man als Verbraucher besser wählen. In anderen Marken stellt sich dann wieder die Frage, gibt es denn überhaupt ordentlich Wettbewerber? Also je nachdem, wie das so ausgestaltet ist. Da werden sich mehrere Themengebiete mischen, die schon lange heftig debattiert werden, aber letztlich von den jeweiligen Regierungen nicht wirklich angegangen wurden.
Also alles, was nicht die Frage ist, warum haben wir nicht unbegrenzt mobiles Internet, ist ja dem nachgeordnet. Also die Frage, wie man die Angebote klar formuliert, die würde sich ja gar nicht stellen, wenn es einfach Internet gäbe. Ich frage mich gerade zu sagen, kann man das Valide fordern, dass man sagt, ihr dürft nicht drosseln, weil das ist menschenunwürdig?
Man kann natürlich verschiedene Ansätze angucken, z.B. in andere europäische Länder. Also was garantieren z.B. andere Länder für typische Durchsätze? Also indem sie in der Regel, die alten Staatskonzerne und deren Konkurrenten gibt es ja oft in europäischen Ländern, dass sie immer Anreize setzen, dass die mehr ausbauen. Da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Ansätze. In Deutschland ist es ja doch eher durchschnittlich. Wenn man so guckt in die digitale Agenda, sind die mehr bezahlen, die sie uns für die Zukunft versprechen, nicht unbedingt an der oberen Spitze. Das andere ist natürlich Regulierungen in Bezug auf, was muss ein Unternehmen dem Einverbraucher wie mitteilen, damit er eben vergleichen kann und eine informiertere Entscheidung treffen kann. Das betrifft aber auch z.B. Vertragslaufzeiten. Also wie lange muss ich denn so einen Vertrag machen?
Das ist jetzt aber schon auch ein Thema, das uns alle nervt irgendwie. Gerade am Monatsende oder bis zum Monatsmitte, wenn dann das Handy, wie er sagt, gedrosselt. Das ist aber auf der netzpolitischen Agenda nicht so weit oben. Also eigentlich bei niemand, habe ich das Gefühl.
Die Drosselung war schon lange, sehr lange im netzpolitischen Diskurs. Beim Breitband erst ein bisschen später.
Aber wir reden ein bisschen aneinander vorbei, weil es geht ja, also wo es ums Lenhardt geht, ist ja, glaube ich, die Drosselung beim Smartphone.
Tatsächlich beim Stand-PC. Ich bin da jetzt im Sonderfall mit hingekommen, oder ich weiß nicht, irgendwer hat gewagt, dass Internet auf ländlichen Gebiet abgedeckt ist, wenn 90% durch DSL oder LTE abgedeckt ist. Das Problem ist, bei LTE wird irgendwann getrosselt. Und das ist nicht irgendwann, sondern nach 30 Gigabyte, was bei DSL-Verbrauch relativ wenig ist.
Also du willst sozusagen auch noch auf die Problematik, dass manche, die nicht in großen Städten leben, am Rande von Städten schlechtere Netzversorgung kamen und dass sich da auch in den letzten Jahren nicht viel getan hat.
Darauf jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Okay, Lennart, ich habe ein bisschen Problemen, dir mittlerweile zu folgen. Was konkret ist deine Frage?
Ich stell sie nochmal. Warum wird quasi nur auf 64 Kilobyte pro Sekunde, Kilobits pro Sekunde gedrosselt und was, was sich nicht auf einen Megabyte so, dass es halbwegs angenehm ist?
Also Drosselung wäre für dich okay, aber es sollte nicht so stark gedrosselt werden. Und du redest tatsächlich von einem DSL-Anschluss, nicht von deinem Smartphone?
Ich rede generell vom mobilen Internet.
Also doch, okay, alles klar. Dann sind wir doch bei dieser Diskussion.
Also ich würde halt zum einen sagen, natürlich auch wieder, damit es halt unangenehm ist, ganz klar, damit du eben noch Heißpiloten dazu buchst und natürlich dem Telekommunikationsunternehmen mehr Geld in den Rachen wirfst. Zum anderen aber auch, und das ist halt auch oft in der Debatte der Fall, was jetzt gerade in ländlichen Regionen damit argumentiert wird, Mensch, wir müssen eine gewisse Versorgungssicherheit feststellen, wie das ja auch mit Strom zum Beispiel so ist. Und dann kommt es halt oft zu Engpässen. Ich habe gestern erst eine Reportage gehört von einem Kollegen, der zum Beispiel über Regionen in Brandenburg berichtet hat, wo Top-Infrastruktur ist, Schule, die in digitalen Berufen ausbildet, die haben 250 PCs und ganz toll smart interaktive Tafeln und die teilen sich alle eine 6M-Mitleitung. Und wenn da, ich meine, habt ihr vielleicht auch schon mal alle so oder du und Lennart auch ganz persönlich kennengelernt, wenn man mit ein paar Freunden zusammen oder auf einer Party oder einem öffentlichen WLAN hängt, dann geht das sehr schnell, wird das sehr, sehr langsam und dann kommt das auf dieses gedrosselte Niveau. Und das ist halt die Dystopie oder die Gefahr, die uns irgendwie auch alle erwartet, wenn ich jetzt mal so den Bogen zur Netzneutralität damit schlagen könnte, dass das oft ebenso ist, dass das argumentiert wird, Mensch, wenn wir alle permanent High-Speed-Stream wollen und nur Videos angucken, dann wird es für alle irgendwie so langsam. Und deswegen, da ist zum Beispiel oft das Argument, Mensch, machen wir es doch anders, schalten wir doch über Holt-Spuren. Wie das im Mobilfunknetz zum Beispiel ist, dass man unendlich viel Musik streamen kann, dass dann eben nicht in das Datenvolumen reingezählt wird. Also auch wenn du nur noch 64 Kilobyte pro Sekunde hast, du trotzdem noch die Alben von dein Lieblingsgünste an dir anhören kannst.
Leonard, ist die Frage dann erstmal beantwortet? Okay, alles klar, dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß dir noch. Ich wollte den Gedanken noch kurz weiterführen, gerade mit der Drosselung, weil man könnte ja auch sagen, die drosseln jetzt und das ist halt ein wirtschaftliches Interesse und da müsste man vielleicht politisch vorgehen, aber ist das bei jedem Thema wirklich so? Da könnte man hier nicht auch sagen, das regelt schon der Markt irgendwie. Also muss man sich da als Aktivistin mal reinhängen, weil ich könnte mir zum Beispiel durchaus auch vorstellen, wenn jetzt alle Konzerne fangen an zu drosseln und sagen, so hier, ab 30 Gigabit auch beim dicksten DSL-Entschluss, erst mal Schluss, dann müsst ihr extra bezahlen, dass dann irgendwann einer der Anbieter für die kommt, na ja, warte mal, irgendwie werden das alle machen und ich jetzt sage 60 oder richtiges Internet, dann kommen ja ganz viele Kunden zu mir. Also kann man sich da nicht auch auf den Markt sozusagen verlassen oder ist das zu sehr ein Wirtschaftsargument?
Das ist natürlich ein Argument, was häufig gebracht wird, unter den Marktgläubigen. Aber man muss natürlich gucken, welcher Markt. Zum Beispiel unterscheidet sich natürlich der Mobilfunkmarkt vom Festnetzmarkt ganz erheblich. Weil wir halt immer noch von früheren Zeiten her, wir hatten ja mal einen Staatskonzern sozusagen, wir haben Festnetz noch eine hohe Dominanz der Telekom, während sich der Markt im Mobilfunkbereich anders darstellt. Also da haben wir halt nicht so einen großen Anbieter, der sehr hohe Marktanteile hat. Entsprechend natürlich andere Märkte, Funktionsmechanismen.
Warte mal, und jetzt fällt mir gerade auf zu sagen, also wenn das wirklich so ist, dass der Festnetzmarkt noch eher dominiert ist von einem Staatskonzern und der Mobilfunkmarkt nicht. Also das Beispiel für die freie Wirtschaft wäre eher der Mobilfunkmarkt und dort ist die Situation mit dem Internet schlechter. Vielleicht beantwortet das die Frage von selbst.
Na gut, das ist aber natürlich auch weiterhin eine Frage des Ausbaus. Und auch der Geschäftsmodelle, die die unterschiedlichen Anbieter im Mobilfunkmarkt haben und aber auch der Transparenz der Dienstleistung. Denn die Verbraucher müssen auch eine Möglichkeit haben, einfach zu vergleichen. Und wenn es zum Beispiel sehr schwierig ist, für die Verbraucher zu wechseln, sie sehr langfristig gebunden sind und schlecht vergleichen können, dann können sie natürlich ihre Marktmacht mit ihren Portemonnaies schlechter ausüben. Und dann haben wir natürlich im Mobilfunkbereich auch keine Bundesnetzagentur, die da großstichetig wird. Wir haben eine Behörde in Deutschland, die sich um den Festnetzmarkt besonders kümmert, weil eben da der alte Staatsmonopolist noch so eine hohe Macht hat. Nämlich die Bundesnetzagentur, also die frühere REC-TP, die ist jetzt umbenannt worden, wie die meisten Behörden. Die kümmert sich halt ganz wenig um diesen Mobilfunkbereich. Das betrifft die ganze Netzneutralität auch, weil sie eben argumentieren, naja, Mobilfunk ist ja Wettbewerb, haben wir ja nicht so Probleme, müssen wir uns nicht so kümmern wie im Festnetz. Dann muss ich auch noch was Drittes sagen. Am Anfang, als es so losging mit dem Streit um damals um die Drossel kommen und die ersten dieser Drosselungen, hat sich noch wenig Widerstand geregt. Erst als ich so durchsetze, fing es an, viele Leute zu stören. Das ist wie so ein typischer Effekt, weil viele merken es, viele stören sich dran, dann kommt erst so ein bisschen Protest auf.
Verzweifelt man da als Aktivist manchmal ein bisschen, wenn man denkt, Leute, wir haben euch vor fünf Jahren gesagt, dass genau das passieren würde. Jetzt, wo es zu spät ist, regt ihr euch drüber auf. Was ist los mit euch?
Ich kann mich darüber eigentlich nicht so ärgern. Ich kann aber verstehen, dass vielen immer sagen, ja, habe ich doch schon seit Jahren gesagt.
Das hilft halt auch keinem.
Mir geht es in anderen Bereichen auch so. Die jetzt nicht mehr Technik zu tun haben, da kriege ich ja Sachen auch später mit, erst wenn sie mich dann wirklich betreffen als Verbraucher. Ich habe da schon Verständnis für eine gewisse Schwerfälligkeit.
Und ich möchte trotzdem auch nochmal über die Priorisierung sprechen. Ihr hattet ja am Anfang gesagt, das Problem ist auch, dass die ganzen Leute, die auf der Aktivismus-Seite stehen, also Chaos Computer Club und Anverwandte und freundschaftlich verbundene Organisationen und Institutionen, haben ein Personalproblem, weil sie einfach nicht die fette Kohle haben und deswegen nicht 100.000 Leute abstellen können. Und jetzt gibt es ja, das haben wir auch schon festgestellt, in der Netzpolitik ein ganzes Themenfeld. Und da gibt es halt so Sachen wie Snowden-Leaks, Geheimdienstüberwachung, Vorratsansprache etc. Und jetzt frage ich mich sozusagen bei diesem Drosselungsding. Da könnte man ja auch sagen, so, also gut, das ist halt doof, dass irgendwie nach 30 GB gedrosst wird, aber 30 GB, das ist halt auch schon erstmal irgendwie ein bisschen Internet. Und es gibt ja dringendere Probleme. Ist das so, dass Netzpolitik auf der Aktivistenseite priorisiert wird, was diese Themen angeht, weil es sozusagen dann wichtige und weniger wichtige Themen gibt?
Also ich glaube, da muss man sehr stark unterscheiden, wer sich wofür einsetzt. Es gibt ja so NGOs, die sich für Menschen oder Bürgerrechte im Netzeinsatz sind, die haben einen relativ engen Fokus. Also spezielle Themen. Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist sicherlich die Free Software Foundation. Die hat halt einen bestimmten Fokus. Da sind manche Bereiche Netzpolitik dabei und manche nicht. Der CCC zum Beispiel hat oft auch einen stärkeren Fokus auf IT-Sicherheit, also auf so klassische Hacker-Themen. Hat aber vor allen Dingen, finde ich, auch immer bei solchen Themen eher noch diese Bürgerrechte im Blick. Also die betrachtet die Netzneutralität weniger unter diesen nur ökonomischen Phänomenen, das ist ja viel Analyse von so Marktwirtschaft, sondern eher in Fragen der Meinungsfreiheit, also wo sind die berührt von Netzneutralität, wenn da jemand wird diskriminiert oder priorisiert. Also es ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich, wie die verschiedenen Organisationen das machen. Wenn man gemeinschaftlich manchmal Kampagnen hat oder wenn zum Beispiel netzpolitik.org auf so eine Probleme hinweist, es ist eben unterschiedlich wer dran geht an die Themen. Und man merkt dann natürlich auch sehr stark, dass da unterschiedlich in die Politik eingewirkt wird. Manche Themen sind einfach für die Wirtschaft nicht so interessant und werden weniger belobbied. Aber hier im Mobilfunkmarkt und überhaupt im Telekom- und Telekommunikationsmarkt geht es natürlich um viele Millionen im Jahr, die man da umsetzt oder nicht. Das heißt, da ist der Druck auch immer höher. Eine andere Sache ist aus meiner Sicht noch, dass die Kampagnenfähigkeit, finde ich, für netzpolitische Themen sehr unterschiedlich ist. Beim Urheberrecht, gerade so Akta war ein Beispiel, da sieht man, wie doch international kampagnenfähig sein kann, während andere Themen wie zum Beispiel, finde ich auch gerade so, diese Drosselungen, waren schwerer als Kampagne zu bauen.
Ich finde das eh bei dem Thema gerade spannend, weil man könnte sich eigentlich denken, so ein in der Zukunft auf uns zukommendes Thema, was irgendein Wirtschaftsvertrag ist, würde ich für viel schwerer vermittelbar halten als Leute, ihr habt zu wenig Internet in eurer Hosentasche.
Ja, da gibt es aber viele Gegenbeispiele. Wenn man mal an TTIP denkt, ziemlich komplexe Themen, internationaler Vertrag ist dieses transatlantische Handelsabkommen.
Und trotzdem gibt es eine relativ... Das meine ich auch gerade. Akta und TTIP sind so komplexe Themen, aber trotzdem gehen da viele Leute drauf und etwas, was man als relativ einfach verkaufbar ansehen könnte, nämlich ihr braucht mehr Internet, das funktioniert gar nicht. Man kann das in dem Beispiel sogar noch doppelt sehen. Das funktioniert nicht nur auf der politischen Arbeit. Es gibt ja auch seit langem diese Freifunk-Alternative, die halt irgendwie versuchen, Städte so auszubauen, dass da sozusagen jeder irgendwie Internet hat. Und das funktioniert umso besser, je mehr Leute mitmachen, da machen aber keine Leute mit. Das heißt, das ist ein ganz einfaches Thema. Trotzdem wird da nicht mitgemacht.
Warum?
Wobei, also bei Freifunk, die verliegen in letzter Zeit, aber haben lange unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit ihre Projekte gemacht. Erst in wirklich, also in den letzten drei, vier Jahren wird so richtig Schwung auf.
Aber selbst das ist ja sozusagen immer noch innerhalb dieser, ich sag's jetzt mal, Nerdblase sozusagen.
Jetzt hat es einfach durch auch öffentliche Artikel, zum Beispiel auch so Lokalsendungen oder Lokalzeitungen, die da aufgegriffen haben, dass so in Städten Projekte porträtiert werden und Leute, die halt Freifunk machen, es hat so ein bisschen Schwung aufgenommen, aber da hängt ja auch noch die Störerhaftung dran, die ja auch politisch heiß diskutiert wird.
Bei jedem Thema, dass du ja aufgehört hast, dass das nächste doch mitgeliefert wird.
Ja, aber so ist die Netzpolitik. Also wie ihr sagt, ich denke, dass es tatsächlich für die verschiedenen Themen auch immer Ursachen gibt, warum manche Kampagnen wirklich heiß und heftig debattiert werden und manche nicht wirklich eine breite Masse erreichen oder erst sehr spät. Das müsste man schon immer am einzelnen sehen. Das beärgert mich auch oft darüber. Wir nehmen den Breitbandausbau. Mittlerweile, diese netzpolitische Szene lacht schon immer darüber, dass sich auch dieses Jahr wieder die Minister auf die Zehe wird stellen und sagen, aber jetzt machen wir wirklich Breitband. Irgendwann machen die seit 10 Jahren. Das ist immer schon so ein Lacher. Oder auch viele Versprechungen, die man jetzt in der digitalen Agenda findet, wo man denkt, ja schön, dass euch das nach so vielen Jahren auch einfällt. Das ist leider so. Aber ich glaube, das wird in anderen Politikbereichen so ähnlich sein, oder? Ich vermute das einfach, dass Leute, die sich, weiß ich nicht, intensiv mit Mondseitschutz oder Klimawandel beschäftigen, so weiter Ähnliches denken.
Das ist die Frage, also gerade beim Breitbandausbau, wer dann letztlich dafür zuständig sein soll, ob man da nicht, also ob der Staat das wirklich verordnen soll oder nicht. Uwe hat noch angerufen und der hat dazu, glaube ich, eine klare Meinung. Hallo Uwe aus dem Wedding. Wolltest du etwas zum Breitbandausbau sagen?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist in der Politik noch gar nicht richtig angekommen, dass das Internet Wirtschaft ist. Und ich meine, dass der Breitbandausbau genauso wie Straßen und Krankenhäuser ein Teil der Daseinsvorsorge des Staates ist. Das muss der Staat bereitstellen. Wie er das tut, da hat er sicherlich viele Möglichkeiten. Aber einen gewissen Mindestausbau muss man da einfach sicherstellen.
Weißt du denn, welche politischen Parteien das konkret fordern oder ob?
Da bin ich jetzt überfragt.
Warte mal, ich würde kurz noch fragen wollen, bist du der Ansicht, der Staat muss das selber machen oder der Staat muss die Firmen dazu verdonnern, dass die das machen?
Er muss es nicht selbst machen. Er kann es selbst machen, aber es gibt sicherlich auch genügend Beispiele, wo es der Staat eben nicht besser macht. Die Telekom sind ja alle froh, dass die Telekom nicht mehr die Festnetze verwaltet. Aber der Staat muss zumindest die Richtlinien setzen, die die Anbieter dazu verpflichtet. Und wenn man eine Vorgabe macht, die zum Beispiel lautet, überall muss ein Internetanschluss mit so und so viel MB pro Sekunde...
Na, na, na, wie viel hättest du denn gern?
Also mir reichen meine sechsten MB pro Sekunde.
Ach komm, ich muss noch an die Zukunft denken.
Das ist aber sehr bescheiden.
Ja, aber mancher würde sich schon freuen, wenn er die überhaupt hätte.
Können wir uns auf 100 einigen?
Ja, das würde die Content-Industrie sicherlich mehr freuen. Dann könnten sie dann gleich drei Filme auf einmal durchleiten.
Also im Endeffekt gibt es ja immer die Problematik, das wird ja auch schon ewig debattiert, dass natürlich in bestimmten Bereichen, also ich nenne jetzt mal wieder diese typischen ländlichen Gebiete, ich kann den Begriff auch nicht mehr hören, dass sich das ja wirtschaftlich dann immer nicht rechnet. Das sagen ja auch die Telcos, also Telco-Mationsunternehmen, dann immer gerne. Wie würdest du da sagen, wie der Stadt damit umgeht, wenn es da so Ecken gibt, also kleinen Fällen siehst du nicht darauf, wo sich das für keinen Konzern rechnet, wird so dann gezwungen werden, die Kabel da hinzulegen?
Niemand kommt auf die Idee zu sagen, Straßen in dieses abgelegtes Fest bauen wir nicht. Es ist selbstverständlich, dass eine Straße dorthin gebaut wird.
Ja, aber wenn ich mal daran erinnern darf, dass die Deutsche Bahn heute auch nicht mehr jeden Bahnhof anfährt, das gibt es ja durchaus.
Ich glaube, da muss ich die Teile der Daseinsvorsorge, sind auf meiner Sicht nicht mit der Wirtschaft zu betreiben. Das kann man nicht mit marktwirtschaftlichen Methoden betreiben.
Klare Ansage. Ich wollte dich ja nur ein bisschen challengen. Ich sehe das ähnlich. Ja, eine klare Ansage.
Wenn man überall einen Briefkasten werfen kann, und der zugestellt wird, muss es selbstverständlich auch sein, dass man einen Breitbandkabelanschluss setzen kann und damit umarbeiten kann.
Komm, lass uns in einem Wahnsinn umsetzen.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, Uwe, wäre eine Partei, die so etwas vorschlägt bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl für dich, wäre das ein starkes Argument, die dann zu wählen?
Das ist ja ein Teil der Politik, das ist ja noch ein kleiner Ausschnitt. Ich glaube, das ist sicherlich ein Gedanken oder eine Erwägung, die mit einer Rolle spielt, aber das ist sicherlich nicht die einzige Erwägung.
Nee, warte, warte, warte, das ist jetzt die Frage. Wäre es wichtig für dich genug, dass es einer der ausschlaggebenden Punkte wäre, oder ist das für dich so, der ferner liefen?
Ich glaube schon, dass es wichtig ist. Die ganze Netzpolitik ist die Zukunft. Da wird man einfach auch sehr viel mehr den Fokus drauf setzen müssen. Ohne Netze, ohne Datenbanken und ähnliches wird Deutschland über eine kurze Zeit den Anschluss verlieren. Das wird einfach nicht mehr funktionieren.
Aber dafür, dass du jetzt gar nicht weißt, welche Partei das tatsächlich fordert, hat so diese richtige, die heutigste Gemeinde zu sehen.
Frau Constanze Kurz, sagen Sie doch mal, welche Partei das fordern würde. Frau Kurz, jetzt hören Sie doch bitte auf, den armen Mann und die armen Hörer so unnötig auf die Folger zu spannen und sagen Sie endlich, welche Parteien in dieser netzpolitischen Position mit Ihnen übereinstimmen.
Tatsächlich hat die Linke in ihrem Wahlprogramm für die letzte Bundestagswahl genau diesen Begriff der Daseinsvorsorge benutzt und dafür auch sehr stark getrommelt, dass sie ein bisschen anders sieht. Tatsächlich haben wir nach der Enquete-Kommission, da gab es ja auch den Streit, ist Breitbanddaseinsvorsorge so ein bisschen schwenk und zumindest in die Richtung haben sich auch andere Parteien bewegt, also vielleicht nicht so klar, muss ja nicht gleich in Sozialismus enden. Aber es ist zumindest populärer geworden zu sagen, ja, da muss der Staat sich zumindest teilweise drum kümmern.
Im Zweifel ist dann aber die Content-Industrie sehr viel stärker. Ich meine, wenn die ganzen Freifunkgeschichten, die du vorhin angemerkt hast, die scheitern ja alle daran, auf billige Art und Weise Netze herzustellen, weil man die Nutzer nicht vom Haken lassen will und sie für Urheberrechtsverletzungen in die Hand nehmen will.
Du willst durch die Blume auch sagen, du hast jetzt auch keinen Freifunkrute?
Der hätte bei uns in der vierten Etage glaube ich auch keine Grüne.
Ach, Ausrede!
Dass wenn jeder eine Tasche an hätte, wäre das schon gehen.
Ich interessiere mich ein bisschen für den Kram, aber jemand, der das mal gut findet, und da denke ich jetzt einfach mal an die Generation meiner Eltern, meiner Spiegeleltern, die nun mittlerweile 70 überschritten haben, das Internet ja gut finden und vielleicht auch so einen Router installieren würden, aber die werden sofort sagen, wenn ich sage, da musst du dann vorsichtig sein, dass du da nicht abgemahnt wirst, dann geht sofort die Klappe runter, dann ist da Feierabend.
Da haben wir sozusagen wieder die zwei Themen. Uwe, dir vielen Dank erst mal.
Ich führe, gerne.
Und viel Spaß noch. Und viel Glück beim Breitbandausbau. Man kommt bei diesen Themen nicht drum herum, das finde ich immer sehr spannend zu sagen. Man sagt also einerseits Breitbandausbau, das müsste mal politisch entschieden werden und so. Andererseits ist dann gleich wieder dieses Störerhaft. Wir müssen das glaube ich nochmal genau erklären. Das machen wir aber gleich. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio auf Fritz im Blue Moon. Es ist ein letzter Donnerstag im Monat. Da findet es statt, dass der Chaos Computer Club hier in die Studios kommt und Dinge erzählt, die mit dem Internet zu tun haben. Heute geht es um Netzpolitik, also um genau was ist denn das eigentlich und wie macht man das und was bringt man das überhaupt alles? Und zu Gast ist Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo und guten Tag. Hallo. Auch vom Blog Netzpolitik Org und da ist auch Florian Gilberg da. Hallo und guten Tag. Moin Moin. Und wir wollen mit euch darüber reden, was ist Netzpolitik und welche Rolle spielt es in eurem Leben? Und dazu könnt ihr Folgendes tun. Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Und weil wir schon, wir haben schon ein bisschen über die Schwierigkeit gesprochen, dass es bestimmte Dinge in Netzpolitik gibt, die an die Politiker heranzutragen, ganz schön schwierig ist, dass es ganz viele verschiedene Themen ist. Und interessanterweise ist in dieser Sendung ein Thema ganz euch sehr wichtig, was normalerweise in der Debatte nicht so die große Rolle spielt, weil da geht es dann dann meistens um Vorratsarten, Speicherung und Geheimdienstüberwachung und die ganzen schlimmen Dinge. Und heute geht es hier so vor allem um Breitbandausbau. Wenn das ein Thema ist, das euch auch interessiert, könnt ihr gerne noch anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Aber wenn ihr ein anderes Thema wollt, könnt ihr es natürlich auch gerne tun, weil Netzpolitik ist ja ein weites Feld. Und wir hatten gerade Uwe dran, der sagte, naja, das mit dem Breitbandausbau, da würde er von Netzpolitik schon erwarten, dass da geklärt wird, das ist halt ein Menschenrecht, kann man das so sagen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß. Daseinsvorsorge heißt das Wort, also das sollte schon der Staatssichtum kümmern, dass wirklich jeder darauf Anspruch hat und das auch aufgeführt wird. Klaus hat auch noch angerufen aus dem Friedrichshain, du würdest auch noch was sagen. Hallo Klaus.
Oh, äh, mal ne Frage, für welche Agentur arbeitet denn die letzte Dame da im Hintergrund?
Bitte was?
Hast du gemerkt, sie den Anruf angenommen hat?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht, das war Fritz. Ich meine die andere Dame, die im Hintergrund sprechen tut.
Die andere Dame, Klaus, sind wir ein bisschen verwirrt? Oder bin ich jetzt in der Dame?
Ja, die von der Partei.
Wir haben hier keine Dame von einer Partei, wir haben hier Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club.
Die von Chaos Computer Club.
Genau, die ist parteilos.
Nee, dummig nicht.
Sondern?
Weil ich denke mal, dass du für den Rosariesen arbeiten tust.
Für den Telekom? Ach du meine Güte, nein.
Klaus, die Sendung ist nur zwei Stunden lang und für Verschwörungstheorien haben wir wirklich wenig Zeit. Doch, das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie.
Warum will der Rosariese die Netzneutralität aufheben?
Na ich denke, der Konzern hat einfach wirtschaftliche Interessen.
Kann jetzt bitte einer von euch noch mal in einfachen Worten erklären, was Netzneutralität ist?
Also es geht bei Netzneutralität um die Frage. Wer darf aus welchen Gründen Datenpakete priorisieren oder aber auch blockieren?
In einfachen Worten.
Behindern, beschleunigen? Also die Frage, wer darf und aus welchen Gründen? Oh was?
So ich möchte Klaus noch mal kurz herunterziehen, um mit der Netzneutralität, Herrgott, weil das immer wieder fällt, das Wort noch mal genauer zu erklären. Es geht darum, wenn man nicht vom einzelnen Datenpaket spricht, sondern sozusagen generell als User, wie man das wahrnimmt, ist es so, dass bestimmte Dienste bevorzugt werden können. Also Telekom User kennen das vielleicht, YouTube Videos gucken ist echt schwierig. Aus eigener Erfahrung weiß ich, dass es einfacher ist, sich ein Netzwerk noch zu klicken, wo man in Großbritannien surft, weil dann die YouTube Videos schneller kommen, weil die Telekom sich auf die Reihe kriegt. Umgedreht würde Netzneutralität bedeuten, als die Telekom sagt, also YouTube ist sehr schnell, aber du musst dann ein bisschen extra bezahlen, beziehungsweise andere Dienste sind leichter. Also es gäbe dann nicht mehr, alles wird gleichzeitig durchs Internet gequetscht, sondern man könnte gewisse Dinge bevorzugen, oder was Florian auch vorhin sagte, deine Internettraffic, deine Bandbreite wird gedrosselt, aber bestimmte Dienste darfst du trotzdem benutzen.
Und zwar geben nach dem Inhalt, also entschieden wird, was schneller durch die Leitung geht, je nach Inhalt. Und das ist ja sozusagen die entscheidende Frage, also gucke ich an, was ist das für ein Datenpaket oder behandel ich alle gleich?
Ganz genau, das ist eben das Ding, was auch so oft zu kurz kommt, um das eben machen zu können und in einer Welt, wo man eben dann so Datenpakete unterschiedlich schnell oder langsam zustellt, muss man eben die Pakete quasi aufschnüllen und reingucken, was ich denn da gerade mir eigentlich angucken möchte.
Also sozusagen nicht nur kein gleichberechtigtes Internet mehr, sondern es ist auch noch, dass man dazu den gesamten Datenverkehr entschlüsseln und mitschnüffeln muss quasi. So jetzt hätten wir das geklärt. Klaus, jetzt nochmal, was war deine Frage eigentlich?
Aber warum will die Telekom, also der rosa Riese, die Netzwerkstellen in den Außenbezirken abkapseln, dass die netzneutralen Anbieter nicht mehr hinkommen?
Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, worauf du hinaus willst. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Also geht es dir darum zu wissen, warum die Telekom gegen Netzneutralität ist oder?
Wenn die Telekom dagegen ist, dann einfach nur, weil sie mehr Geld machen kann, wenn in Zukunft keine Netzneutralität mehr gibt. Na ja klar. Und die sind ja selber auch Inhalteanbieter. Also die Telekom zum Beispiel, wenn wir an die WM denken oder so. Und für die ist es schlicht, ein neues Geschäftsfeld wird sie aufmachen können, wenn sie bestimmte Daten schneller durchlassen. Und wenn sie das vor allen Dingen dürfen, das ist ja eine gesetzliche Frage, ob man das darf und in welcher Art man das darf. Und die Debatte haben wir halt nicht nur für die Telekom, sondern wir haben sie auch gleich noch in Europa. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass das nicht nur bei uns debattiert wird, das gibt es ja nicht nur bei Telekom, sondern natürlich auch in Europa. Und da nun mal ein Großteil dieser Festnetzkunden immer noch bei Telekom sind, ist ja ein alter Staatskonzern, ist natürlich die Entscheidung der Telekom für viele Menschen, die da kunden sind wichtig, weil eben der größte Anbieter ist im Festnetzbereich und die machen eine ganz gute Lobbyarbeit. Die versuchen natürlich ihre geschäftlichen Interessen durchzusetzen. Zum Beispiel.
Gut, hätten wir das geklärt. Vielen Dank Klaus und jetzt nochmal zu der Netzneutralitätsdebatte. Welche Positionen habt ihr da und wie versucht ihr die umzusetzen?
Also bei dem Chaos Computer Club ist ganz klar diese Informations- und Meinungsfreiheit wichtig. Denn Netzneutralität dreht sich ja eigentlich längst nicht nur um geschäftliche Fragen, sondern auch immer um die Frage, wer darf sich von wem informieren lassen. Also wer kann zum Beispiel alles, was er am Markt gemacht hat, seine Inhalte schneller an den Mann bringen. Also ist tatsächlich diese kleine Blog noch genauso schnell zu klicken, wie eine bekannte Newsseite mit vier Werbung, die vielleicht zu einem großen Konzern gehört. Kann ich zum Beispiel ein kleines Geschäft haben, was ich nicht auch, ein Videokanal hat, die selben Geschwindigkeiten haben, wie etwa jemand, der bei YouTube ein Video anguckt. Und es ist für uns eher auch eine politische Frage und auch letztlich wieder eine technische. Denn wie kann man denn so eine Netznotalität brechen? Welche Technik braucht man denn, wenn man solche Filterungen, ja, Priorisierungen, wenn man die durchsetzen will? Denn da ist gleichzeitig immer die Frage dabei, jemand muss in diese Datenpakete reingucken, um den Inhalt zu bestimmen, den er priorisieren will oder blockieren will. Und da ist eine imminent politische Frage, ob jemand während der Verkehr durch seine Infrastruktur läuft, in die Datenpakete hineinsieht und dann eben die Weiche nach links oder nach rechts stellt. Das heißt, so richtig menschenrechtliche Fragen, also Meinungs- und Informationsfreiheit sind ja in der hohen Rechte.
Ganz genau, da wollte ich auch noch gerade anknüpfen. Also auch von Nutzerseite ist es ja extrem wichtig, auch sage ich jetzt mal von unserer Sicht von netzpolitik.org, dass man eben Chancengleichheit gewährleistet, dass wenn wir alle dann irgendwann nur noch den ganz langsam gedrosselten 64 Kilobit Zugang zum Netz haben und dann eben draufzahlen müssen für alles, was wir zusätzlich machen müssen, also sage ich mal Monatspaket YouTube kostet noch mal 5 Euro mehr, wenn du Facebook benutzen willst kostet nochmal 10 Euro mehr und so weiter, dann wird die Zahl der Nutzer, die sich das Internet noch leisten können, sehr viel kleiner, aber die Wahrnehmung wird ja wahrscheinlich trotzdem nicht geringer werden in der Öffentlichkeit. Das heißt, es bestimmen immer weniger Leute, immer mehr die Themen und das Internet wird zu einem militären Medium und das ist absolut der falsche Weg.
Dann haben wir quasi so eine Art Fernsehen wieder mit wenigen Kanälen, die wir benutzen können oder zumindest man muss es sich leisten können, das ganze Internet zu erleben, das ist eine spannende Frage. So, jetzt haben wir jetzt auch noch einen spannenden Typen am Telefon, zwar Toni, der von sich sagt, der würde bei der Telekom arbeiten. Hallo und guten Abend Toni.
Grüß dich, hallo, grüße euch allesamt. Ja, also ihr könnt euch schon mal drauf einstellen, also die Telekom hat schon IPTV. Natürlich hat sie das, also ich meine, alle Telkurses, ich finde das irgendwie immer ein bisschen dämlich auf die Telekom raufzurun, weil eigentlich im Grunde alle Telkurses das gleiche wollen. Sie wollen eigentlich ein Internet haben, was eigentlich das ist, was wir vom klassischen Fernsehen kennen, das hätten sie am liebsten. Also heute wird mit den Services geworben, irgendwie, ich meine.
Die Telekom ist halt im Fokus, weil sie ein großer Anbieter ist. Und auch, weil sie dem Staat gehört, irgendwie sind wir quasi über den Stadtbesitzer der Telekom.
Ja, genau, und weil wir für 8, 50 Euro da sitzen. Ja, du lachst dich, weil das ist die weiche Flanke in der Netzpolitik, die soziale Flanke irgendwie in der Netzpolitik irgendwie sehr selten bedient wird. Das muss man dazu eigentlich auch sagen. Na, was ich damit meine ist tatsächlich, wenn man sich so anguckt, die großen Internetunternehmen, das sind ja nicht nur die Telekoms irgendwie, geh zu Amazon zum Beispiel, geh irgendwo anders hin, geh zu diesen großen Unternehmen, sie zahlen irgendwie für den Maschinenraum 8, 50 Euro in Deutschland, also wirklich den Mindestlohn, die zahlen für ihre großen Mitarbeiter sehr, sehr viel. Also es sind einfach klassisch international aufgestellte, große Unternehmen, die, ja, also ich meine, man muss sich angucken, wie zum Beispiel Google und Facebook irgendwie in San Francisco die Gentrifizierung irgendwie vorantreibend mit macht.
Okay, warte, Toni, Toni, nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell, nicht überall hin, nochmal ganz von vorne. Du arbeitest bei der Telekom?
Ich arbeite im 2nd Level bei der Telekom, genau. Das ist da, wenn du zum Beispiel ankommst und sagst irgendwie du hast Probleme mit deinem Entertain und so und dann kommst du erstmal nicht zu mir, sondern dann kommst du zu jemanden, der versucht das so zu lösen und wenn es im Router Neustart nicht klappt, dann darf ich ran.
Okay, verstehe. So und jetzt zur Netzneutralität.
Genau und das Problem ist, du merkst immer mehr, dass sie abdriften, sie wollen immer mehr für ihre Services Geld haben, sie möchten am liebsten, ja, dass du für jeden Furz eigentlich zahlst. Also egal was du machst irgendwie, du, also mein Raum ist natürlich, es fällt IP aus meiner Dose, am liebsten irgendwie ein 100 MBit Anschluss, ja. Das wird irgendwie in Zukunft so wie das aussieht nicht sein, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Sie werden irgendwie auf irgendwelche Services aufsetzen. Wenn du was haben willst, musst du dafür zahlen. Also das ist manchmal schon eine Lächerlichkeit, wo du manchmal denkst so ja, okay, also früher konntest du den Leuten noch ein Outlook einrichten, dafür sollen wir heute 5 Euro im Monat zahlen. Das sind so kleine, einfache Sachen, aber das ist...
Meinst du jetzt konkret bei dir jetzt auch der Job, den du machst, also das als Serviceleistung?
Als Beispiel, aber sie wollen natürlich auch für Netzleistungen irgendwie, dass du Geld zahlst, sei es das Fernsehen. Ich bin sicher, also die Telekom hat schon angefangen bei T-Mobile zum Beispiel, hier dieser Tarif, wo du irgendwie für Spotify extra irgendwie nicht, du hast ein bisschen mehr gezahlt, dafür wurde Spotify nicht aufs Volumen angerechnet. Das fand ich schon eine ziemlich grobe Verletzung.
Das ist eine ganz, ganz klar.
Das wird auch im Festnetz kommen, da bin ich mir sicher, dass sie anbieten werden.
Jetzt bist du aber schon so ein bisschen fatalistisch, glaubst du also das gar nicht mehr zu ändern?
Ach man, ich bin immer auf Notze irgendwie, ich hab schon einfach genug gesehen und du hast vorhin selber gesagt, du hast auch recht irgendwie, ich bin doch groß geworden, da haben sich die Leute noch aufgeregt, dass Christian Schwartzscheligen irgendwie Kupfer hat verlegen lassen damals, falls du dich erinnerst, ja und kein Glasfaser sozusagen fürs Kabelfernsehen und es rauskam, dass irgendwie sein Schwager so eine Kupferfabrik gehört hat, ja so eine Kabelfabrik.
Damals schon, ja.
Heute wär ich mir nicht so sicher, muss ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen, ja. Also die Zeiten haben sich einfach geändert, also ich auch, wenn man sich also wenn man sich wenn man sich anguckt, wie Europapolitik betrieben wird, die die Leute von der Industrie sitzen an Stellen, man fühlt sich einfach, also das ist eben sehr fatalistisch. Ich geh zu, man fühlt sich tatsächlich total machtlos. Wie hättest du es denn gerne? Wie ich es gerne hätte, ich hätte gerne tatsächlich irgendwie die Infrastruktur, egal ob das jetzt Internet ist oder Wasser oder Strom, tatsächlich in öffentlicher Hand. Also das muss ich dazu ganz einfach sagen.
Boah krass, wirst du überhaupt wieder Staatsbeamter?
Nein, das hat mit Staatsbeamter nichts zu tun. Ich denke öffentliche Infrastruktur ist eine Sache, von der jeder profitieren muss, auf eine Art und Weise.
Ich habe durchaus verstanden, das war die Forderung, das war jetzt ein bisschen schranzhaft.
Ich finde persönlich, Infrastruktur ist keine Sache, die abhängig sein muss vom Geldbeutel. Und ich meine, in Deutschland haben wir sogar noch eine Situation im Verhältnis zu anderen Ländern, wo mittlerweile schon Wasser in private Hände gegangen ist, wo es noch verhältnismäßig gut ist. Und ich denke aber, wir sehen tatsächlich in anderen Ländern, wo Leute sich schon Wasser nicht mehr leisten können, schon fast eigentlich unsere Zukunft irgendwie blinken auf eine Art und Weise. Das ist sehr fatalistisch, ich gebe es zu.
Aber warum können wir das politisch nicht auch erreichen? Also ich meine, das kann man doch als Forderung formulieren, nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, ich gucke mich auf meine Arbeit um, ich sehe irgendwie unsere ganzen Mindestlöhner, wie wir alle rumstreunen. Ja, ich weiß, ich wähle und ich wähle sehr links irgendwie, nicht wie seit Jahren links. Wie du siehst, hilft das seit, jetzt bin ich 47, wie lange darf ich wählen? Und seitdem hilft das nichts, ja, stimmt, das hilft wenig.
Och, jetzt macht es uns aber jetzt total, jetzt geht es nicht.
Ich mach euch nicht runter, nein.
So, jetzt Toni, letzte Frage, du arbeitest bei einem Konzern, mit dessen Politik du nicht so einverstanden bist.
Warum?
Hast du schon mal versucht, wenn du mal krank geworden bist, keinen Abschluss hast, irgendwie eine Arbeit zu kriegen, dann bist du froh, wenn du irgendwo einen Job kriegst. Das ist immer das Problem. Du guckst dich bei uns auf Arbeit um, es arbeiten total viele verschiedene Leute bei uns. Es sind viele Leute, die gestrauchelt sind, auch viele Leute, die krank geworden sind, viele Leute, die älter sind. Ja, das ist einfach manchmal so.
Also, du musst dich mit der Politik des Konzernes ja nicht gleich machen, nur weil du da arbeitest.
Also, das denk ich auch.
Aber meinst du, dass du Ärger kriegen konntest, wenn dein Chef das hier hört?
Nein, ich glaube auch nicht, dass mein Chef sich das anhört.
Schade eigentlich, oder?
Ja, vielleicht sollten die Chefs das mal hören.
Deswegen muss man Netzpolitik machen, da redet man auch mal mit den Chefs.
Toni, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
So, das ist ja auch sehr missant. Das ist natürlich auch so eine schwierige Frage. Und das, gerade was Toni jetzt gesagt hat, man ist halt manchmal gezwungen bei der Firma zu arbeiten, wo man halt gar nicht übereinschätzt. Also das liebe Geld ist dann halt auch auf ganz anderer Ebene.
Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, glaube ich, für Markus. Eingangsfrage, Markus fragte ja so am Anfang, warum sich eigentlich so wenige engagieren. Man muss sich schon klar machen, auch wenn man selber jetzt, zumindest für mich selbst kann ich jetzt sagen, Netzpolitik natürlich sehr wichtig finde, so ein Zukunftsthema, dass viele Leute ganz andere Sorgen haben, um die sie sich jeden Tag kümmern müssen. Das ist immer so ein bisschen der Vorwurf, ja, ihr engagiert euch zu wenig, natürlich für manche Leute einfach auch nicht zutrifft, weil die ganz andere Sorgen haben. Wir müssen sich irgendwie auf Wasser halten oder so.
Also krass formuliert, Netzpolitik ist schon ein Luxusproblem.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht mehr. Dafür ist das Politikfeld zu breit und dafür interessieren sich auch zu viele Leute dafür. Auch zu viele Politiker übrigens. Also damit das Feld ist nicht mehr so ein Nischen politisches Feld und das hat auch mittlerweile viele soziale Fragen, die damit hineinspielen. Gerade beim Breitband und dieser Daseinsvorsorge ist das ja schon bei. Aber auch bei anderen netzpolitischen Fragen. Also etwa Beteiligung, das ist ja auch nur soziale Frage.
Also sagen, die hinterstehende Idee ist, man muss dafür sorgen, dass die Leute online kommen, weil wenn man das nicht macht, hängt man diese Leute von der politischen Willensbildung ab, oder?
Sicher auch bei Netzneutralität. Also soll nicht vom Geld abhängen, ob ich mich unabhängig informieren kann. Also es sind schon immer auch Fragen bei, die breiter sind, die eine ganze Gesellschaft betreffen. Vor allen Dingen aber in Zukunft auf jeden Fall betreffen werden.
Ich würde jetzt gerne noch zu dem Thema zurückkommen, was wir relativ weit vorne schon angesprochen hatten, nämlich das mit der Politik. Wir hatten ja schon festgestellt, die Hauptentscheidungen werden immer getroffen von den Machtpolitikern, die dann wiederum beraten werden. Aber ist denn das so, dass man Parteien eindeutig Netzpositionen zuordnen kann? Weil es ist doch jetzt auch so, dass auch die großen Parteien sozusagen Netzverbände und vereinzelt blickt da auch Kompetenz durch. Wie ist denn das?
Die Politik hat es halt extrem in den letzten Jahren entdeckt. Ich meine, wir haben ja auch seit der letzten Bundestagswahl gab es ja auch groß angekündigt, die digitale Agenda und im Kollektionsvertrag verankert. Und alles sollte viel besser werden. Die IT-Sicherheit sollte ausgebaut werden. Und wir steuern in eine rosige Zukunft. Und heute stehen wir irgendwie dann trotzdem noch da. Und es ist irgendwie wenig passiert. Aber ja, wie du gerade schon meintest, es gibt halt schon Verbände auch innerhalb der Parteien, denen man das jetzt gar nicht mal so als Kernkompetenz zurechnen würde, wo sehr gute Leute auch sind und arbeiten und da durchaus was machen. Aber die dann halt trotzdem vielleicht oftmals durch die klare Parteilinie daran gehindert würden, sich dann aber auch anders organisieren.
Also oft sind es natürlich auch so gegenteilige Interessen, die gegeneinander abgewogen werden müssen. Freiheit und Sicherheit zum Beispiel ganz oft. Natürlich gibt es in allen Parteien mittlerweile ein oder mehrere Fachpolitiker und netzpolitische Sprecher natürlich mittlerweile. Also klar, jeder kennt, die Bundeskanzlerin äußert sich ab und an zur Netzpolitik. Wir haben die netzpolitischen Sprechrunden, die der Innenminister schon mal eingeäutet hatte. Da ist schon was passiert.
Es gibt auch innerhalb von Parteien sozusagen gegensätzliche Meinungen.
Es ist natürlich auch in allen Politikverhältnissen.
Also gibt es CSU-Politiker, die gegen die Vorzeihansprechung sind?
Ja, natürlich. Es sind aber nicht die Schwitzenpolitiker.
Und dann halt die Frage, woher kommt das? Also das scheint ja so, als ob sie sagen, also ich verstehe nicht, wie das dann sein kann. Also wenn man denken würde, es geht um inhaltliche Argumente, also nur um inhaltliche Argumente, dann müsste es ja eine klare Haltung geben.
Ja, aber ich glaube, jeder weiß, dass in der Politik inhaltliche Sachfragen nun nicht immer die entscheidende Rolle spielen. Also in gewisser Verständnis habe ich dafür auch. Also man muss sich überlegen, ja, wie sieht denn der Bundestag, da sind viele Leute, es gibt viele viele Themen und nicht jeder weiß überall Bescheid. Und in der Regel gibt es eine Fraktionslinie. Und das Abstimmungsverhalten ist entsprechend, da gibt es auch keine Abweichung.
Wodurch wird sie denn festgelegt? Und vor allen Dingen, wieso kann sie sich von den Fachlauten unterscheiden?
Na, es gibt natürlich erstmal gegensätzlich politische Meinungen. Wir nehmen mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder wir können das auch bei Netzneutralität machen oder beim Datenschutz. Es gibt eine Konservativ-Behaltung. Klar, will man oder will man nicht. Damit bedient man aber auch Wähler. Man muss natürlich auch sehen, dass sich das genauso in der Wahlbevölkerung abbildet. Es gibt einen Anteil der Deutschen, die möchte diese anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Zumindest schreckt es sie nicht vom VN ab.
Aber das hört sich so an, als ob die Netzpolitik stellenweise so gemacht wird, dass da nur die Haltung draufgeklatscht wird, die zum jeweiligen Label der Partei passt und dass es nicht um Sachargumente geht.
Doch, das ist häufig so. Klar, wurde ein Label daran geklebt. Als die FDP noch im Bundestag war, hat man eine typische freiheitliche Position gesehen, die keine Vorratszeitenspeicherung hat. Die hat die damalige Staatsministerin vertreten. Und die Konservativen haben gesagt, die versprechen damit Sicherheit, also wollen wir das auch haben. Und generell auch eine wirtschaftsfreundlichere Position, die in der Regel von den Konservativen vertreten wird. Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Klassiker.
Aber jetzt, als ihr wiederum die Frage an euch als Aktivisten, wenn man jetzt sozusagen weiß, es geht eigentlich in großen Teilen gar nicht um die inhaltliche Argumentation zu dem Thema, sondern da wird einfach eine Haltung tradiert. Wie arbeitet man damit? Oder sagt man dann einfach so, es macht halt eh keinen Sinn, mit der und der Partei zu sprechen, weil man die gar nicht überzeugen kann, weil es da nicht um inhaltliche Dinge geht?
Man muss halt nicht an der Parteiebene ein bisschen ansetzen, sondern wie du auch gerade schon meintest, es gibt ja die Strömungen und die Leute in Parteien und ich meine, die nächste Wahl kommt halt bestimmt und wer weiß, wie die Machtverhältnisse dann aussehen. Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass sich die Leute dann auch da anders zusammenschließen oder gucken wir zum Beispiel auf europäische Ebene, wo sich Leute auch in anderen Fraktionen, als es auf Bundesebene der Fall ist, dann zusammenschließen und da können dann ja auch ganz andere Machtverhältnisse entstehen.
Also ich glaube, es sind auch mehrere Ebenen. Das eine ist, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel auf Netzpolitik org blickt, da geht es ja viel auch um Information. Also Sachen erklären. Beim CCC ist es auch häufig so, dass wir, wenn jetzt nicht gerade Wahlkampf ist, eigentlich mit allen Parteien sprechen. Ich glaube, außer den Nazis. Ich glaube, es nutzt immer, ein sachliches Gespräch zu führen. Denn der Informationsbedarf ist vielfach da. Wir werden im CCC auch einfach häufig gefragt, zum Beispiel, was die Themen sind, die wir für zukünftig besonders wichtig halten. Es gibt schon Informationsbedarf. Es gibt auch in der Politik den Bedarf, sich gerade kommerziell unabhängig informieren lassen zu wollen. Der ist schon da. Klar, das erlebe ich auch relativ häufig. Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch die Gegenöffentlichkeit, die man versuchen muss herzustellen, wo zum Beispiel netzpolitik.org ein Mittel ist, wo aber auch viele NGOs in diesem Bereich Kampagnen fahren und einfach viel erklären, eine Gegenöffentlichkeit bilden. Weil natürlich Wirtschaftsinteressen in den Zeitungen relativ gut abgebildet werden, weil die eine ordentliche PR machen.
Ich bin an dieser einen Stelle hängen geblieben, wo du gesagt hast, okay, mit allen Parteien sprechen, weil sach die Information ist auch wichtig. Aber ist das nicht erstens super frustrierend, zu einer Partei zu gehen, wo man jetzt schon vorher weiß, die werden trotzdem ihre Meinung nicht ändern? Und läuft man nicht vielleicht sogar an Gefahr, dass man als Schmuckblatt verwendet wird? Also wenn die sagen, eine Partei, die für die Vorwarnzeit schon bei sich ist, dann kann man sagen, ha ha, wir haben ja auch mit dem CCC gesprochen. Aber trotzdem ist es nicht kontraproduktiv für das öffentliche Bild?
Na ja, sind ja zwei sehr unterschiedliche Fragen. Eine ist natürlich frustrierend, manchmal, wenn man bemerkt, dass Sachargumente, die man bringt, manchmal auch technisch zwingende Argumente, gibt es ja auch, überhaupt nicht beachtet werden. Oder dass man zum Beispiel, wenn man eine Stellungnahme abgibt, eigentlich schon an einem Punkt im Gesetzgebungsverfahren ist, wo man genau weiß, die haben ihre Meinung schon gebildet. Und selbst wenn man manchmal in Ausschüssen sitzt, oder so im Bundestag, wo die Gesetze gemacht werden, und merkt, eigentlich sind alle Sachverständige, nicht nur man selbst, als CCC, wenn da ein Vertreter sitzt, sondern auch die anderen, zum Beispiel auch die Juristen oder andere Techniker dagegen, das frustriert. Aber andererseits, wenn man ein bisschen langfristig guckt, habe ich oft den Eindruck, dass in netzpolitischen Themen steht der Tropfen, den Stein schon höht. Es gibt einen Streit über zehn Jahre über die Vorzeitsprechung und die Argumentation hat sich schon verändert. Und manche Argumente können nicht mehr wegdiskutiert werden. Also die politische Argumentation ändert sich. Und bei manchen Sachen, da merkt man, okay, die Schlacht ist irgendwie nicht zu gewinnen. Und bei anderen schafft man den. Und manchmal muss man einen langen Atem haben. Bei der zweiten Frage ist es, diese Feigenblatt, also nutzen die einen selbst. Darüber streiten wir uns oft. Deswegen, also im TTC ist es so. Das sind Wahlkampfzeiten, da halten wir uns ein bisschen stärker fern von Parteien, weil wir eben nicht, wir wollen da nicht vereinnahmt werden. Andererseits ist es natürlich auch im Wahlkampfzeiten manchmal ganz schön wichtig, dass man versucht, diese Position abzuklopfen und auch klar zu machen, dass man zum Beispiel danach guckt, was nach der Wahl ist. Dass man nicht nur Wahlprogramme liest, sondern auch guckt, ob die die später umsetzen. Und was eigentlich dann im Koalitionsvertrag steht. Also das ist ein schwieriger Grad. Und natürlich hängt es letztlich auch von diesen Netzpolitikern, Fachpolitikern an. Manche sind einfach echt sympathisch und zugänglich, hören zu. Und manche sind einfach arrogante Leute, mit denen man eigentlich nach einer Weile nichts mehr zu tun haben will. Das ist ja auch manchmal die Nette oder nicht. Und dann natürlich auch die Macht, die die in einer eigenen Partei haben. Ist es jemand, der das schafft, sich auch Mehrheiten zu organisieren? Oder vielleicht sogar einen Parteitagsbeschluss? Oder ist das eh so ein Hinterbänkler? Das fragt man sich natürlich.
Du musst halt schon auch priorisieren. Die wollte ich gerade sagen. Gibt es ein Thema, das du aufgegeben hast?
Für mich persönlich ja. Es gibt Themen, wo ich mich persönlich nicht mehr engagiere, weil ich einfach hinterherweige, weil ich es lange getan habe. Oder weil ich glaube, das gewonnen oder verloren. Für den CCC würde ich es aber dennoch tun. Ich bin ja eine Weile in gewisser Weise auch ein Sprachrohr. Und ich glaube auch bei Netzpolitik ist es so ähnlich. Da werden auch manchmal Themen abgebildet, wo man jetzt nicht gleich die große Kampagne plant, also in der Redaktionsarbeit. Im CCC gibt es Sachen, die ich derzeit für gewonnen erachte. Das ist etwa die Debatte um Wahlcomputer. Da werden wir in den nächsten paar Jahren noch Ruhe haben. Das wird wiederkommen, nämlich in Form von Onlinewahlen. Aber so derzeit verfolge ich nicht mehr großartig, nur noch mehr aus so akademischem Interesse. Aber ich persönlich kann mich heute auch nicht mehr so stark beim Urheberrecht einbringen. Das war für mich ein ganz langer Thema. Aber das überlasse ich dann eben anderen. Da gibt es Gott sei Dank CCC genug, die sich dafür interessieren. Und Netzpolitik Org ist zum Beispiel auch gut vertreten. Aber da kann ich mich persönlich nicht mehr einbringen. Da habe ich den Eindruck, schon so oft in Diskussionen gesessen zu haben. Einfach auch schon so lange. Und ich kann auch ehrlich gesagt dann diese Debatten dann nicht mehr... Aber das sollte man auch nicht. Man muss ja auch Herzblut haben, eh jedenfalls, für Sachen. Und wenn ich merke, da bin ich jetzt überdrössig, dann wende ich mich anderen Themen zu. Das ist ja die Netzpolitik.
Also Netzpolitik ist nicht nur komplex, sondern auch kräftezehrend. Und wir haben noch gleich noch eine halbe Stunde. In der möchte ich über etwas sprechen, was jetzt immer wieder zwischendurch so ganz kurz auftauchte. Das war nämlich das Wort Europa. Was das mit Netzpolitik zu tun hat, das klären wir gleich. Aber erst gibt es die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Manche denken, sie haben es geschafft, wenn sie ihr eigenes Flugzeug haben. Oder ihre eigene Insel. Er, mein Name ist Casper, hat sein eigenes Festival. Fritz präsentiert Casper's Festival. Natürlich mit Casper, aber auch Prinz Porno. Und das Line-Up ist noch nicht komplett. Wer noch dazu kommt, bleibt spannend. Live von Obenmeer in der Wohlheide.
Um kurz nach halb 12.
Fritz, Nachrichten.
Mit Emily Ulbericht.
In Düsseldorf ist am Nachmittag die Wohnung des Co-Piloten der abgestürzten German Wings Maschine durchsucht worden. Die Ermittler hoffen, Hinweise auf sein Motiv zu bekommen. Der 27-Jährige soll die Maschine vorgestern absichtlich zum Absturz gebracht haben, als der Kapitän das Cockpit kurz verließ. Air Berlin, EasyJet und mehrere andere Fluggesellschaften haben inzwischen festgelegt, dass kein Pilot mehr allein im Cockpit bleiben darf. Bei der Lufthansa ist man geschoppt über die neue Entwicklung beim Flugzeugunglück. Lufthansa-Chef Spohr sagte am Nachmittag, was passiert sei, mache ihn fassungslos. Gleichzeitig sprach er von einem tragischen Einzelfall und betonte, dass er volles Vertrauen in seine Piloten habe. Das Cockpit-Personal werde bei Lufthansa sehr sorgfältig ausgewählt. Laut Spohr wurde bei dem 27-Jährigen nichts Auffälliges festgestellt. An vielen Berliner Schulen ist heute Unterricht ausgefallen. Auch einige Prüfungen mussten verschoben werden. Schuld war ein Warnstreik der Angestellten Lehrer. Sie gingen am Mittag für eine bessere Bezahlung auf die Straße. Aus Brandenburg kamen etwa 500 Lehrerinnen und Lehrer zur Demo nach Berlin. Und zum Sport-Basketball-Pokalsieger Alba Berlin darf weiter auf die Teilnahme an den Playoffs in der EuroLeague hoffen. Die Albatrosse gewannen am Abend gegen den serbischen Vizemeister Roter Stern Belgrad mit 73 zu 68. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Schöneberg 5 und in Treptow 6 Grad, in Frankfurt Oder und Brück 6 und in Prenzler und Neuropin 5 Grad. In der Nacht ist es weitgehend trocken bei 5 bis 3 Grad, morgen bleibt es kühl bei 8 bis 12 Grad. Dazu wieder viele Wolken und ab und zu auch Regen. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100, Stadtring Richtung Neukölln. Die Einfahrt Siemensdamm ist wegen Reparaturarbeiten gesperrt. A111, Stadtautobahn statt auswärts. Zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdamm und Schulzendorfer Straße ist die Straße wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Das Ganze noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Charlottenburg Masurenallee zwischen Theodor-Häusplatz und Messe-Damm gibt es Behinderungen wegen der Echo-Verleihung. Das Ganze auch noch bis morgen früh 5 Uhr. Und Mitte, die Invalidenstraße ist zwischen Gartenstraße und Caroline-Michele-Straße wegen Bauarbeiten in Richtung Moabit gesperrt. Und noch nach Brandenburg A9, Berlin Richtung Leipzig. Zwischen Beelitz und Brück gab es einen Unfall und es liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn und die rechte Spur ist gesperrt. Und A10, Berliner Ring, Dreieck Werder Richtung Dreieck Potsdam zwischen Dreieck Werder und Gelindo steht ein kaputter Laster auf dem Standstreifen. Allen unterwegs eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de slash.
Musikstreams Tschüss Das Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritzsee mit Markus Richter noch eine halbe Stunde und außerdem zu Gast Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Und Florian Gilberg vom Blog Netzpolitik.
Ich bin auch noch da, genau.
Das ist ja verrückt. So und wir haben über Netzpolitik gesprochen, die ersten anderthalbe Stunde und wir haben darüber gesprochen, wofür ihr euch bei Netzpolitik interessiert und das Thema, das euch am meisten interessiert, ist der Breitbandausbau, die Netzneutralität, also die Tatsache, wie viel Internet bei euch ankommt und wie frei ihr das benutzen dürft. Netzpolitik ist ziemlich komplex, man muss an die Politiker rankommen, man muss die Themen da irgendwie platzieren und es kann auch kräftezehrend sein. Und während der Sendung ist immer wieder gefallen und Europa, also Netzpolitik scheint nicht nur etwas deutsches zu sein, sondern auch vor allem in Europa stattzufinden vielleicht. Oder wie muss man das einschätzen? Welche Rolle spielt Europa in der Netzpolitik für uns jetzt konkret hier?
Man kann eigentlich sagen, wie in anderen Politikbereichen wird immer mehr nach Europa verlagert, kommt dann eine sogenannte Verordnung oder kommt eine Richtlinie, die bindet dann die Nationalstaaten. Wir haben das gesehen beim Datenschutz, wo das mal eine gute Sache sein kann oder eine schlechte Sache sein kann. Wir sehen das aber in eigentlich allen Bereichen beim Urheberrecht, da es eben versucht wird, ja, da Politik zu machen bei Netzneutralität. Und wir haben halt in Europa ein Problem mit einem Digitalkommissar, der Günther Oettinger heißt, ein absolut digital Unbeleckten zu haben. Er hat also auch klettermaßen überhaupt keinen Plan über Digitalien, wird aber wie immer von vielen Lobbyisten dabei beraten, wie man trotzdem Politik machen könnte. Also wir haben diese Problematik, dass wir eben nicht mehr nur über unser eigenes Land nachdenken müssen.
Aber, also bevor wir nochmal drüber reden, wie das dann in Europa ist mit der Netzpolitik, wie wird so jemand eigentlich Digitalkommissar, das ist ja nicht so, dass ein deutscher sozusagen Wirtschaftsminister ein Machtpolitiker ist, wie ihr am Anfang erklärt habt und kein Sachpolitiker, kann man sagen, naja gut, das ist ja aber auch so, also ich mein Wirtschaft ist jetzt auch ein so weites Feld, da gibt es halt eh keinen einzelnen Experten. Aber ein Digitalkommissar, das ist doch jemand mit einer ganz klar umrissenden Aufgabe.
Es ist aus mehreren Gründen, es ist schon ähnlich wie in der deutschen Politik, nur noch schlimmer. Denn man hat natürlich ein Länderpropos, dass bestimmte europäische Länder Kommissars Posten kriegen, aber man hatte vor allen Dingen diesen Örtigen, der mit irgendetwas abgespeist werden musste. Das ist ja so eine Art Dankes-Post und es hat überhaupt nichts mit Kompetenz zu tun. Das wird auch nicht so getan, als sei das so. Ja und es ist so erheitend, wie er über Netzpolitik redet, dass man wirklich, man kann Schmerzkrämpfe vor Lachen kriegen. Wir haben uns teilweise über die Reden. Das ist wirklich faszinierend.
Und auch was mit einer deutlichen Sprache da geredet wird. Also wir wurden auch erst vor zwei Wochen als Taliban bezahlt, weil wir uns für Netzpolitik konzentriert haben.
Wird der was?
Ja, wörtlich Talibanartig.
Er wirft uns eine Art oder allen, die sich in der Netzpolitik so einbringen, dieser sogenannten Netzgemeinde, nennt die auch so, so Extremismus vor in gewisser Weise. Das soll ja wohl dieser Vergleich bedeuten. Er hat auch total Vergleiche, wo man einfach merkt, er hat selbst mit dieser digitalen Welt gar nichts zu tun. Also Analogien, die nicht passen oder und dann kann er auch noch, also er kann es auch nicht ausdrücken. Er schafft es auch nicht, grammatikalisch korrekte Sätze zu bilden. Also seine Reden sind wirklich, vielleicht würdet ihr noch besser, aber seine Reden, die ersten, die waren wirklich, die waren eigentlich nur für Internethumor geeignet.
Okay, vielleicht ist das ja Absicht.
Was?
Na ja, Internethumor ist sozusagen ein großes Kommunikationsmittel und vielleicht will er sich sozusagen so einen Platz in der Netzgemeinschaft haben.
Schlau kalkuliert.
Das könnte durchaus sein. Aber jetzt sag mal, also in Europa werden sozusagen quasi die Vorgesetze für unsere Gesetze geschaffen, könnte man so sagen. Die gibt es so und die alle sagen ja Organisationen, die ich kenne, sozusagen also Netzpolitik, Chaos Computer Club und was es da alles noch gibt. Die sind ja, das sind ja deutsche Organisationen. Habt ihr dann auch noch, sagen Leute in Brüssel oder wie läuft das?
Also ich denke bei Netzpolitik war das, also als bevor es eigentlich richtig große Blog wurde, was auf hier gelesen wurde, schon immer eine gewisse Kooperation da, dass man mit anderen europäischen Bloggern damals noch oder mit Leuten in Brüssel geredet hat. Beim CCC, finde ich, waren wir relativ spät, uns auch europäisch steiger zu vernetzen. Denn es ist nicht so, wie du gerade gesagt hast, dass das so eine Vorgeletze sind. Es gibt natürlich insbesondere alle Verordnungen aus Brüssel, werden unmittelbar geltendes Recht hier in Deutschland. Also je nachdem, welche Art da beschlossen wird, kann das sofort gütig sein. Und ich glaube, der CCC hat das glaube ich eine Zeit lang nicht so gut gemacht, mit der Vernetzung ist aber deutlich besser geworden. Das ist vor allen Dingen natürlich auch aus meiner Sicht die Problematik, dass wir nicht wirklich eine europäische Öffentlichkeit haben. Man hat eben in den Zeitungen, liest man zwar bei Europa, aber auch aufgrund der Sprachbarriere, wird glaube ich immer noch sehr national gedacht. Das merkt man glaube ich bei manchen Debatten mehr, bei der Datenschutzdebatte vielleicht ein bisschen weniger. Da gibt es ja tatsächlich eine europäische Debatte.
Aber hat das dann sozusagen zur Auswirkung, dass die Politik nach Europa verlagert wird, aber da sind gar nicht die ganzen Netzaktivisten, dass dann da eher die unschönen Dinge besprochen und entschieden werden?
Naja, wir haben halt schon auch Netzaktivisten auf europäischer Ebene, aber ich meine, Brüssel wird ja nicht umsonst oft genug als Lobby-Hauptstadt der Welt so ein bisschen betitelt, wo ich weiß nicht die aktuelle Statistik, aber drei Lobbyisten auf einen abgeordneten ganz bestimmt kommen.
Hm, 3, 0 irgendwas auf jeden Abgeordneten. Ja, immer so ganz grob.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel die größte netzaktivistische Organisation, EDRI, die da sitzt und das sind aktuell zweieinhalb Stellen, die da versuchen, bürgerliche Positionen, netzaktivistische Positionen durchzusetzen. Und da sieht man ja schon ganz akut, wie chronisch unterbesetzt das alles ist und unterfinanziert auch.
Es gibt natürlich mittlerweile auch, wenn es um die Menschenrechte angeht, ein bisschen Professionell lobbying. Also wenn wir an sowas wie Endless International Denken oder Human Rights Watch, also große internationale Lobby-Organisationen, die zumindest ein paar Mann in Europa haben, das gibt es mittlerweile. Aber die waren natürlich deutlich später als die Wirtschaftsverbände, die diesen Schuss wie früher gehört haben und gemerkt haben, wo eigentlich die Gesetze gemacht werden und wo die Kohle sitzt.
Aber ist das sozusagen die fachfremden Nichtregierungsorganisationen, agieren die denn da in eurem Sinne oder haben die eigentlich ein anderes Thema und machen Netzpolitik so nebenbei?
Es kommt natürlich auch wieder auf die Organisationen an. Also Endless International hat zum Beispiel tatsächlich einige netzpolitische Themen, wo man sich freuen kann, weil die natürlich auch sehr gute Kampagnen machen und weil die sehr präsent sind in den Medien, auch international. Oder bei Human Rights Watch gibt es ein paar Ecken, die das betrifft. Netzpolitische Themen können ja durchaus mit den Menschenrechten zusammenfallen, also etwa in der Drohnendebatte, da gibt es ja durchaus ein paar Schnittmengen. Oder wenn man über Überwachungsfreiheit als Menschenrecht redet, wir haben ja auch eine europäische Menschenrechtskonvention, die uns zu sagen, diese Privatheitsfragen als Menschenrechtsfragen darlegen, da gibt es so Schnittmengen, aber die Arbeit zumindest, wenn man das so vergleicht von NGOs, EDI, also European Digital Rights, wo sich viele NGOs aus Europa zusammengeschlossen haben und MST oder Human Rights Watch arbeiten schon sehr unterschiedlich, denn da sind einfach andere, naja, Manpower MST ist, eine internationale Organisation und Human Rights Watch, die auch eine andere finanzielle Basis haben. Und in Deutschland sind traditionell diese NGOs, die sich da einsetzen, wie die Free Software Foundation oder eben auch der CCC, nicht mit viel Geld oder im CCC-Fall sogar ehrenamtlich tätig. Also da sind einfach wenige Menschen.
Das erinnert mich an eine spannende Frage, weil diese ganzen großen Organisationen, die haben ja auch ganz viele Spenden.
Genau, die finanzieren sich auch so.
Und das ist ja in Deutschland ist es ja eher nicht so, gerade bei Netzpolitik, da wird ja immer wieder um Spenden gebeten oder wird sogar aufgerufen. Irgendwie Sascha Lobo hat ja letztes Jahr auf der Republik noch mal extra einen Vortrag gehalten, mit mehr Geld in die Hand. Glaubt ihr, dass sich das irgendwie ändern wird, dass auch da eine Crowdfunding-Finanzierung im weitesten Sinne des Wortes mal an den Start kommen kann? Oder wird das ewig so bleiben, so unterbemittelt, könnte man sagen, unterbemittelt und ungeliebt?
Ich meine, in einigen Bereichen funktioniert das ja schon ganz gut, wir von netzpolitik.org sind zum Beispiel größtenteils Community finanziert. Wir finanzieren zum ganz kleinen Teil noch das Werbeanzeigen oder auch Stellenanzeigen, aber uns bezahlen quasi unsere Leser.
Ja, aber das ist ja sozusagen eine ganz andere Größenordnung als sowas wie Amnesty International.
Ja, aber auch mit wenig Geld kann man da auch schon viel bewirken. Ich meine, natürlich, Sascha Lobo hat dann auch das Beispiel der Bikasini-Wars, glaube ich, angebracht, mit der Umweltbewegung, also mit einem Vogel in Bayern, der eben akut gefährdet ist und wo es, ich glaube, acht oder zehn Vollzeit-Lobbyisten quasi in dem Sinne gibt, die sich den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigen, für diese Bikasini-Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen und eben Spenden zu akquirieren.
Ja, ein sehr plakatives Beispiel.
Ja, aber wenn es klappt, also wenn es funktioniert, das Beispiel.
Ja, hat auf jeden Fall anscheinend so gut funktioniert, dass wir auch einen klaren Anstieg an Spenden und an Unterstützungen danach verzeichnen konnten. Auch nochmal vielen Dank dafür an dieser Stelle, sag ich mal vom ganzen Team, denke ich mal. Aber es ist natürlich noch nicht aller Tage Abend. Und wir sind froh, dass das momentan so funktioniert, wie das weitergeht, wie die Zukunft zeigen wird.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen, also ich meine, das hört sich jetzt sozusagen ganz positiv an, aber es ist, da wird halt ein, ich sage mal, mittelgroßes Block finanziert. Nicht Lobbyarbeit in der Politik, das ist ja der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus wollte. Während halt diese ganzen großen Organisationen halt tatsächlich dann dadurch Einfluss haben, dass es ist. Und dann sind wir wieder bei der Anfangsfrage, die Markus Becke dargestellt hat. Also sagen, warum interessieren sich so wenig Leute dafür? Und Interesse in diesem Fall vielleicht auch nur, keine Ahnung, halt da auch mal Geld zu geben.
Interesse muss ja auch nicht immer ein Geld sein. Kann ja auch als eigenes Engagement sein.
Aber hilft schon, oder?
Der Inhalt, ja klar. Also ich meine, also komm, wir sind ja hier nicht nur marktkonform. Aber ich beobachte natürlich gerade zum Beispiel im Vergleich mit den USA. Das ist eine andere Spendenkultur hier gibt. Also wenn ich die FF sehe, die Electronic Frontier Foundation und wie die sich in den USA finanziert oder eben auch die Großen eben wie Amnesty. Schon ein Unterschied. Aber muss man auch sagen, Amnesty International hat eine lange Tradition. Also das ist ja auch so ja viele Jahre Arbeit, die da drinsteckt und die Netzpolitik. Wir haben ja am Anfang erwähnt, das Blog ist zehn Jahre alt, der CCC hat ein bisschen über 30 Jahre. Zwar auf dem Buckel, aber auch ein politischer Akteur. Es ist ja noch nicht so furchtbar lange, weil Computer noch nicht so furchtbar lange vor der Image benutzt werden. Aber ich glaube, das wird sich aufbauen. Florian vergleitet manchmal gerne mit dieser Umweltbewegung, oder?
Ja, ist so ein bisschen Wunschraum. Ich meine, man kann es ja so ein bisschen sehen. Wir sind aktuell an dem Punkt vielleicht da, wo die Umweltbewegung war. So irgendwann hat man halt gemerkt, ja, scheiße, die Atomkraft ist vielleicht auch nicht so sicher, wie immer gesagt wird. Oder jetzt im Netz, wir sind vielleicht doch nicht so unbeobachtet, wie wir uns immer fühlen. Ja, und irgendwann hat es den Leuten halt dann auch gereicht.
Aber glaubt ihr, dass das wirklich passieren kann? Also weil so, also wenn wir, wenn wir, oh Gott, der Vergleich wird bestimmt fürchterlich auf die Füße fallen, aber naja, wenn man sagt, so die Snowden Leaks sind so eine Art Supergau für die Informationsgesellschaft.
Das würde ich total unterschreiben. Es wird ein Paradigmenwechsel einleiten mit dem ganzen Verzeugnis.
Aber hätte der nicht schon kommen müssen?
Ich denke, der ist, der ist im Gange. Ich denke, er passiert gerade. Aber dadurch, dass wird kein, es ist nicht wie bei Fukushima, sozusagen so ein plötzlich Umkippen in der Politik. Ich glaube, dass wird eher ein langsamer Prozess sein wird. Aber er hat schon begonnen. Ich finde, er ist auch schon stark zu beobachten.
Und dann ist aber sozusagen eine Frage, die ich stelle, die, also wenn man jetzt die Umweltbewegung zum Vorbild nimmt, oder vielleicht auch die Friedensbewegung, da gibt es ja ganz klare Ansagen. Da kann man sagen, so keine Atomkraftwerke, keine Atomwaffen, sondern halt irgendwie schwerer zu Flugscharren und Windkrafträder und Solarenergieren lang. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, dass es in der Netzpolitik keine so klaren Handlungsempfehlungen gibt. Es gibt immer sowas wie Netzneutralität, brauchen wir, aber es fällt viel schwerer, dem einzelnen User ganz klar zu sagen, worauf er hinarbeiten soll. Ist das auch ein Problem, dass es zu abstrakt ist?
Es gibt halt ganz, ganz, wir haben uns das auf die Fahnen geschrieben, Fight for Digital Rights ist so das Motto von Netzpolitik und jeder Einzelne kann ganz viel tun und das muss nicht Geld sein. Das kann auch einfach nur fünf Minuten Aufwand sein.
Du hast meine Frage gerade völlig missverstanden, kann das sein? Meine Frage war sozusagen bei Friedens- und Naturbewegung, da kann man sehr klar und sehr eindeutig kommunizieren, was das Ziel ist. Das Ziel ist nämlich keine Atomkraftwerke mehr.
Und da steckt noch eine Vision hinter.
Und vor allen Dingen, man kann das aber auch als einzelner Mensch ganz einfach begreifen, nämlich ich möchte keinen Atomstrom. Sondern ich möchte halt sozusagen, ich möchte Impressen. So und jetzt irgendwie, wenn ich, gerade wenn man so in der Netzpolitik so was sagt, wie verschlüsselte Kommunikation ist super, das ist so ein Ziel, da kann man sich darauf einigen. Aber frag mal einen Beliebigen und dafür würde euch beide hier vielleicht sogar dazuzählen, welche verschlüsselte Lösung ist jetzt die beste? Dann kriegt man halt irgendwie nicht so eine klare Antwort, wie du brauchst ein Windrad, sondern dann gibt es halt ganz verschiedene und noch nichts ist perfekt und so weiter und so fort.
Auch in der etwa Öko-Bewegung, in der Friedensbewegung, in der Umweltbewegung sind natürlich die Antworten nicht einfach in einer komplexen Welt. Aber man kann auch für Netzpolitik natürlich solche Forderungen, hinter denen man sich zusammenscharen kann, sozusagen stellen. Zum Beispiel, nehme ich mal den Beispiel Datenschutz. Man kann als Titel oder als Motto formulieren, ich möchte auch in Zukunft unüberwacht kommunizieren können. Das ist ein einfacher Ziel. So wie ich sagen kann, ich möchte keine Kernenergienutzung oder so. Ich denke, das geht schon. Man kann sagen, bei Netzpolitik möchte ich nicht, dass meine Datenpakete durchgeguckt werden und dann eben priorisiert blockiert oder schneller weitergeleitet werden. Das ist eigentlich schon eine einfache Forderung. Ich gebe zu, dass es Bereiche gibt, wo es komplexer wird. In der IT-Security ist mir das häufiger passiert. Ich habe ja gegenüber der Presse auch oft so diese Klärbärfunktion. Da wird es manchmal komplexer. Aber ich glaube, für viele netzpolitische Bereiche kann man sehr wohl einfache Ziele benennen. Das heißt nicht immer, dass die Lösungen einfach sind, die man dafür anstrebt. Aber das ist in der Umweltbewegung auch nicht so. Und es ist bis heute auch bestritten, wie die richtig sind. Ich finde nicht unbedingt, dass es ein Muss ist. Ein Ziel ist ein Muss. Und dass man eine Vision hat, ist auch ein Muss, glaube ich. Also eine Idee, wie die Zukunft aussehen soll. Und wie sie irgendwie besser ist. Und vielleicht nicht ganz so Kommerz. Lieber Bürger als Konsument so, ja. Aber es muss nicht unbedingt eine trivial einfache Lösung sein.
Ja, aber vielleicht eine, die wenigstens trivial einfach zu verkaufen ist. So, die Sendung ist ja dann auch bald schon wieder vorbei. Ich würde zum Schluss noch von euch wissen wollen, was sind denn so die Themen, also A, was sind die großen Themen, die wir jetzt nicht angesprochen haben, dass wir die wenigstens kurz so mal genannt haben. Und B, was sind denn die großen Themen, die dann demnächst mal anstehen? Was kommt denn dann noch auf uns zu netzpolitisch?
Ja, das schaffen wir aber nicht mehr in 10 Minuten, Florian wird es versuchen mit schneller Sprache.
Muss ich jetzt runterkrattern? Ja, also...
Ja, mit dem Tempo?
Ich muss mal Luft holen, mich ein bisschen wappnen. Ganz akut steht immer noch an, wie wird das denn ausgehen mit dem Überwachungsskandal? Werden wir den aufklären können? Wir hatten, wie ich eben schon mal in der letzten Woche, ein Jahr den NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss und wir sind irgendwie keinen Schritt weiter gefühlt. Also hat der BND mit der NSA kooperiert und der willentlich Daten geliefert. Besteht da sogar eine Kooperation, von der wir nichts wissen sollen. Wird dieser Untersuchungsausschuss da Licht ins Dunkel bringen können? Und wenn ja, selbst wenn das rauskommt, dass das so gewesen ist, was wird das für Folgen haben? Werden sich die Leute dann aufregen und sagen, haben wir eben mal gewusst, so? Das ist eine große Frage. Urheberrecht ist eine ganz konkrete Frage, auf die wir auch schon gesprochen haben. Da steht auf europäischer Ebene die EU-Datenschutzverordnung an.
Was, was, was? Du hast gerade Urheberrecht gesagt und dann Datenschutzverordnung.
Wie hängt das zusammen?
Das ist eine Aufzählung, Markus.
Wir sind schon den nächsten Schritt weiter.
Wir haben nicht so viel Zeit.
Netzhartalität steht auch noch an. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wird auf europäischer Ebene auch ebenfalls entschieden, ob das rechtens ist, ob das in irgendeiner Form in Deutschland doch und in anderen europäischen Ländern umgesetzt werden muss.
Da möchte ich noch keine Nachfrage einfügen, weil ich dachte, da wurde schon entschieden, dass jetzt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die wurde doch in Deutschland abgesagt, weil es auf Europaebene ein Gerichtssortell gab, das sagt er so, nee, so nicht.
Ja, man wartet dann aber noch, wie das da konkret ist und da besteht anscheinend noch Klärungsbetrag, ob das dann in Deutschland doch wieder eingeführt werden kann oder nicht.
Also es gibt eine Menge deutsche Politiker, die können doch einfach deutsche und europäische Urteile ignorieren. Das stelle ich mich nicht so an, Markus.
Du hast doch gerade gesagt, dass du euch die europäische Ebene vorgibt und dann sofort Recht und Gesetz wird.
Ich hätte diese Vorratsentsprechung für Untot. Ja, aber es ist ja nur eine Debatte, die wiederkommt. Also wir haben ja kein Gesetz gesehen. Denn in Wirklichkeit haben doch alle Vorschläge, die jetzt zu kommen, adressieren überhaupt nicht, was die Richter in die Urteile geschrieben haben. Da steht eine Menge interessanter Zeug drin. Man kriegt ja nie konkrete Vorschläge, die sagen immer nur, ja warum Wort dann? Aber wie sie das eigentlich machen wollen gesetzlich und den beiden Urteilen, also dem Bundesverfassungsgericht und dem europäischen Urteil gerecht zu werden, das sagen die nicht mal mehr. Also ich halte das mehr so für Schrammeln. Das ist so untote Schrammeln. In Wirklichkeit ist sie doch tot.
Na, wir sind gespannt.
Vielleicht ist das auch eine Hoffnung von mir. Florian, los, wir haben hier mehr Themen.
Sind wir schon durch oder?
Also ich denke, es werden vor allen Dingen rechtspolitische Probleme sein. Also was wird weiterhin mit den Abmahnungen, die einfach viele Leute, Tiere stören, wie wird das politisch geregelt? Was wird mit der Störerhaftung passieren? Wie ist das mit diesen sogenannten, die ganze Frage, wie wir Kontrolle über unsere Geräte haben? Also was dürfen Hersteller einbauen? Weil in Zukunft vor allen Dingen die sogenannten TPM-Ships, also auch technische Fragen. Das sind manchmal auch eher Verbraucherfragen. Also darf ich mir Software installieren? Oder darf ich jetzt nicht? Solche Fragen. Es wird aber auch umsoweit gehen wie Fair IT. Ach, das sind netzpolitische Themen. Was ist das? Wie ökologisch kann man eigentlich Rechner herstellen? Solche wichtigen Fragen. Wir werden ganz sicher in der Netzpolitik über Big Data, dieses Wirtschaftsschlagwort von einer massenhaften Datenverarbeitung sprechen. Das wird kommen. Wir werden über Algorithmen streiten müssen, die unser Leben bestimmen, weil sie Entscheidungen für uns treffen. Das werden wir auf jeden Fall tun. Wer unter welchen Umständen darf das? Wir werden über Monopole reden, weil es bestimmte Märkte im Bereich von Internet gibt, wo bestimmte Unternehmen ganz hohe Dominanz haben. Klar, da werden unglaublich viele Streitthemen sein. Wir werden auch wieder, wenn die Zukunft ein bisschen weiter geht über Online-Wahlsysteme, das kommt doch wieder, vielleicht in fünf Jahren oder so. Ich glaube, uns werden die Themen auf jeden Fall nicht ausgehen. Und wir werden ganz sicher über allem, weil das die Basis sein wird, über sehr viel IT-Security reden müssen. Also die Sicherheit in Netzen, in Software, in Briebsystemen, das wird so ein begleitendes Thema immer sein. Also wir haben spannende Themen, oder?
Aber wird das dann sozusagen eine politische Diskussion sein? Oder wird das dann auch Hand in Hand gehen, wie das da auf Wahlcomputern, Schach gespielt wird oder ähnliche lustige Dinge?
Also in Deutschland ist der Markt, der ist ein Markt aus Sicht der Anbieter, der ist erstmal tot, weil wir ein deutliches Urteil aus Kartsrohr haben. Wir haben Vorgaben, die gemacht wurden.
Ich meinte generell, weil du sagst, IT-Security ist so ein großes Thema, ist Netzpolitik, wird sich das immer weiter zu einer abstrakten Diskussion entwickeln oder wird auch der praktische Hack, der Spaß am Gerät, da noch eine Rolle spielen?
Na ja, gut, im CCC spielt natürlich so ein praktischer Hack, das sind die Wahlkapitale, das sind ja ein Beispiel, oder der Schatz Trojaner oder so, wird weiterhin eine Rolle spielen. Ich glaube, die politische Diskussion, die läuft natürlich in der Regel ein bisschen anders. Klar kann man, wenn man so einen großen Hack hat, die beim Schatz Trojaner, kann man auch politisch daran Forderungen knüpfen. Aber die klassischen netzpolitischen Debatten sind eher so Marathonläufe, wo man sich einfach jahrelang streitet, immer wieder versucht, Sachargumente anzubringen und so weiter. Und auch teilweise so Lobby-Sachen einfach aufzudecken und eben diese Gegenöffentlichkeit herzustellen. Ich glaube, das hat auch mit Zielen zu tun. Also warum nützt du dich für bestimmte netzpolitische Sachen?
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade noch fragen. Es gibt diese riesige Palette, ihr seid jetzt aber zwei Leute, Constanze Kurz und Florian Gilberg. Und ich würde von jedem von euch noch ganz kurz wissen, was ist das eine Thema, was auf eurer nächsten Agenda steht? Florian?
Was drauf steht und was drauf stand und auch noch stehen wird, ist Überwachung definitiv. Wie können wir uns schützen? Was können wir machen, um global Überwachung zu verhindern? Und zwar sowohl von Staaten als auch von Konzernen, die uns ausspionieren, die Profile über uns anlegen, wo wir fast überhaupt keine Kontrolle mehr drüber haben und das uns auch noch in 10, 20 Jahren verfolgen wird. Man sagt so schön, alles, was du jemals gegoogelt hast, wird gegen dich verwendet werden. Das birgt enormes Gefahrenpotenzial.
Constanze? Ich könnte nicht ein Thema sagen, weil ich einfach, wenn man für einen Verein spricht, mich immer mit vielen Themen beschäftige. Aber es gibt natürlich ein Thema, wo ich besonders viel Herzblut drin habe und was mich derzeit sehr interessiert auf mehreren Ebenen. Das sind für mich Drohnen. Und zwar vom Militär bis zu Kleinstdrohnen und Spielzeugen. Mich interessiert diese Technik derzeit sehr. Wohin sie sich entwickelt, ich denke da gerne über Technikfolgenabschätzung nach. Da habe ich den Eindruck, mich auch engagieren zu müssen. Aber ich könnte nicht sagen, dass ich mich auf ein Thema stürze und nicht gehe.
Na gut, es gibt ja genug zu tun. Wir haben in den letzten zwei Stunden reichhaltig versucht zu erklären, was Netzpolitik ist und was auch ihr oder wofür ihr euch da interessieren könntet. Wenn ihr es noch mal ganz genau nachhören wollt, der Podcast zu dieser Sendung wird im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de erscheinen und dann sicherlich später auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de und Constanze macht aufgeregte Gesten. Was ist denn los?
Unbedingt müssen wir noch darauf hinweisen, dass ihr klicken müsst auf events.ccc.de denn wir werden diesen Sommer ein Camp haben. Und kürzlich ist eine Hacker-Truppe zur Besichtigung gefahren, hat sich Gelände angeguckt.
Also wer sich informieren will, events.ccc.de Wird im Sommer ein Camp stattfinden, das heißt Zelte und Hacker, alles auf einem Haufen. Draußen und nackt. Wir beenden die Sendung an dieser Stelle und verweisen auf die angegebenen Webseiten und wünschen euch dabei viel Spaß. Das Chaosradio gibt es nächsten Monat nicht hier auf Fritz, sondern im Chaos Computer Club Berlin live in der Marienstraße 11 vor Ort. Mit Bild und Tonik könnt ihr gerne vorbeikommen, wenn ihr wollt. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight mit Henrik Schröder. Dabei wünsche ich euch viel Spaß. Vielen Dank, Constanze Kurz und Florian Gilberg. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich sage nur noch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Pack-ups.